Unknown: What do you think you're doing? Who do you think you are? I was really curious about, I came up with a class that used to be in the U.S. I'll do that. How many units? Sorry. Oh, yes. So I looked up over the last two years. So you're kind of just saying, how are you? I would say, like, 60,000. Oh, 60,000. 6,700. How are you? That's good. Yeah.
Unknown: And of course, it's all, like, multiple. I'm whiteboard.
Vikki Dipple: We claim as many saveable parts as we can in the system, but we don't know if anybody's ever going to know.
Jake Herwaldt: But the longer, there's probably this weird window of like the longer, the older it gets, the more valuable. But at some point, then it just falls off.
Vikki Dipple: Then at some point, the system is no longer.
Jake Herwaldt: It's too old. That's a weird thing to price. Do you guys have a good mechanism to understand this part? Probably we'll have, and here's the end of life, so we should keep it 10 years post-end of life, and then just throw it away.
Vikki Dipple: Some of that in like a polyurethane, but there's not a report or any kind of system, because a lot of these engineers can make anything work again. A system that's 30 years old, no problem, because it itself has changed. You know, you might put a new cover on it.
Unknown: not a lot of innovation at the time i i can yeah it started too important i was good you.
Unknown: guys find that she made them oh those are quite good oh this is yours oh thank you yeah was it.
Jake Herwaldt: like a sour cream uh cream cheese something was creamy just enough for a boost to wake up.
Vikki Dipple: i forgot i didn't have breakfast this morning i had so much at dinner last night i went out to dinner with my mom she lives in we went out to olive garden nice i haven't been in olive garden. yeah but she's like.
Erica Smith: Oh, they work.
Jake Herwaldt: Genuinely, my entire life I was like, why is marketing the thing? Ads make no sense. And then I'm sitting there with my wife one night. We just got married. A Snickers commercial came out and she was like, Snickers does sound good. And my wife's personality is like, okay, I need to leave right now to go get a Snickers. I'm like, that is insane. This is literally why it exists. That's crazy.
Vikki Dipple: So the number one that we've sold through sourcing with them is those Halo.
Jake Herwaldt: Okay, really.
Vikki Dipple: Oh, I don't doubt that. All for class two, class three. Is that what we see now.
Jordan Clark: Yes, that one.
Vikki Dipple: How did you pull this out? Um, I have a report that shows all of the sources.
Erica Smith: I've spent a lot of time watching that one.
Unknown: Oh, that one's good. Oh, we see that. Can I enforce directly as your computer works? Yeah, well, let's see. I can run on board. That one's nice. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Steve Muniak: So, whoever put the parking lot up at one is too high.
Jake Herwaldt: That was me. That was all me.
Nathan Bedford: I wouldn't have noticed. That's got no...
Sam Binder: That's going to bother you though.
Nathan Bedford: Yeah, not seeing it. Oh, wait. I can't see it now. If it was crooked, it would bother me more.
Steve Muniak: And they just put up that decal. And I think the decal is straight, but the line is straight, but the trim on the top end of the decal looks to go... Tapering off the logic. It tapers off just a bit.
Erica Smith: They shouldn't have made the grids. You can't point that stuff out. That's all I'm going to see now when I watch. Not that I'm here often, but once a week is enough. Yes, right. We're here for the turn of the wand on Sunday.
Erica Smith: You guys need to be here. That was quite good. They weren't my best, I forgot. Okay. I didn't know if that was going to fit. It's a little longer, though. But it seems to be working. Yeah. Yeah, there's some that are a little bigger.
Erica Smith: Don't worry about it. I just want to make sure. I feel like the laser is hard. Laser is hard. I've done that, too. I learned my lesson. Exactly. That's hard to do, right? That's like the maple wand. She looks cute, but this is...
Steve Muniak: Well, we had a party, and then now, somebody had taken all the salt from me, so I'm not going to be doing that again. This is why I'm like, we need a system.
Jake Herwaldt: Oh, my God. No, you've got to look at my discovery. Did anybody notice what I saw? Yeah, they were like, you can't hide that.
Unknown: Yes, yes, yes. I had a good cherry on the tray. Oh, no. I was like, well, this is my favorite part of the day. Yeah, that was just milk. Oh, my God. You know what? It's a funny story, right? It's a different thing. Sometimes there's a meal from Texas. But I take that on, and I'm like, why are we doing that.
Nathan Bedford: You've got to just let it go. Rain or man. You see it? Rain or man. But we, uh-huh. It's a time to. They have a party.
Sam Binder: I don't want to be anywhere close to that.
Erica Smith: She gets it right there. She would love that. She brought it back to me.
Erica Smith: She would not be perfectly like...
Steve Muniak: Erica, if you don't mind...
Erica Smith: So, my name is Erica Smith. I am a team. What that is, we are the team that supports our internal field for whole service contracts, whether that be the Siemens multi-vendor side or the legacy to differentiate. That could be requests coming into us direct, that could be coming in our service CSRs, or we actually have re-supporting management. We are usually working from internal people and external clients.
Steve Muniak: I've been using the term.
Erica Smith: the buy side. Yes. At least on the sell side. Correct. I think of it as internal and external. So we support the internal customers. We support their team support. Whatever verbiage works for you to make the connection. That's what I do. Erica, do you have any idea on total contracts on your business? It's a lot. Growing every day? I mean, it's definitely increased and drastically changed probably in the past maybe months in the Project 19. I think it's a lot.
Erica Smith: I think it's a lot. I think it's a lot. I think it's a lot. I think it's a lot. same project management. What is it? Tens a day? Just for order of magnitudes. Are you looking order? Like quantity of parts? Like how many quantity of parts? How many boxes get sent out or how many? So. And it doesn't have to be not nowhere exact number. It's like oh five to ten or the twenty or. I will say um just at the point of this as you wish. In August alone I did. Your worst quarter. Order. Yeah order is not. Correct. So that's at least one part. But that's at least.
Erica Smith: Yeah. Sometimes there's two to three, there's occasionally been...
Andrew Bailey: And you're figuring what are the blockings.
Erica Smith: Correct. So when we submit our part request, it will automatically tell us if there's anything in order, whether it's a finished good or a service that's here in Rancho or boarding stuff. From there, a little digging to make sure the part is what we need it to be to ensure that it's coil and those lines. It's something that we don't have.
Andrew Bailey: I just realized we skipped a step. How many do you guys realize we skipped.
Sam Binder: Oh, God. You want me to do that too.
Erica Smith: I mean, I mean... Yeah, are you trying to be selective about this.
Vikki Dipple: Well, we wanted to start with introductions.
Andrew Bailey: Yeah, we haven't got introductions yet. And then we rolled on. We were getting into questions where I skipped a step. I was testing you guys again, and you guys didn't. I mean, skip all the steps you want.
Erica Smith: We just gotta do.
Erica Smith: No, Erica, we need to know. Oh, don't worry. You will know.
Erica Smith: It's more of the, are you ready for when you want to know.
Andrew Bailey: Here's the introduction. We believe that Block is working. Okay, so there's two things. Oh, bummer. But anyway, you get to participate in our genius.
Vikki Dipple: Can you complete this.
Andrew Bailey: And then for the people you don't know.
Vikki Dipple: I have to go look to even see what my...
Erica Smith: I keep it in my email. You know what? You don't just pick on it all day long? No. I don't.
Erica Smith: Well, she's not like us, Sam. I'm not going to be next to... I was going to say, does that mean... I'm pretty sure I do... I'm pretty sure wonder is... I don't know what it is. Our goal was... Struggle. How can we make this happen.
Andrew Bailey: Our goal was to help us see that, we'd at least heard that Block, uses this as a tool for organizing. So we have a lot of tenacious...
Erica Smith: I can pretend to be.
Vikki Dipple: But it's not my true self. I remember the words competency. That's the middle... Where you can do it for a little while, before it starts to burn you out, and you'll be fine. It's also just called like.
Andrew Bailey: Yeah. No, I was told if I stayed in my jeans, I'd never get tired. That's why you didn't go to sleep for 60 hours. That's why I try not to learn too much about anything. I just try to invent things and pretend I know what I'm talking about. Plumpy. I can do that for anything. He's pretty good at it. Well, I just, I did want to have the full experience. Because I know we're going to ask you to kind of, probably drill more procedurally,
Andrew Bailey: through. And so I didn't want to. I knew I was going to get distracted and add details, before we get started. And.
Erica Smith: I think I just might.
Andrew Bailey: We're. I think we're nervous. Yeah. No, I'm using a word that's probably not fair. I think these processes are very simple. In this, our fear was that what Sam had initially provided in an overview, she was hiding certain complexities. And then as we got through, we're like, oh, wait, that's not exactly what she said. We're aware of the opportunities for improvement.
Andrew Bailey: We're aware of some of the ideas for advancement. But that's pretty straightforward. It's not complete right now as we have it up there. But honestly, we want a standard. You need something. I need something. All right, something to sell. I need something to buy. Those processes all made sense. They were aligned with what we would expect of product.
Unknown: Yeah. Right.
Andrew Bailey: I think we're nervous that this internal process is very – products follow – So when you use something, Spotify, Apple, music, Amazon music, they're very similar. Oh, wait. This one's your chair, right? Right there. Right in the middle. Well, yesterday she invented some whole thing for us, so keep her there.
Andrew Bailey: And Amazon follows product rules, and they're kind of familiar to us. We often say that products, the best products, you don't need to learn how to use them, because they make sense with everything else that you own, right? There's actually humans that are devoted to making sure that your product is innovative in a particular way of producing value. It's not also hard.
Vikki Dipple: I think that's why that up there is as smooth as it may have appeared to be because Sam and I were dedicated on making sure that at least it's... Internally, the look of it and the function was as best as we could make it, the other developers, but then internally, we were able to get to the point where it's understandable in a way that it's not like every single time I do something, it's a workaround.
Andrew Bailey: So, my suspicion, I want to throw out some language categories that we're going to use together. My suspicion is two or three things. I have two in my mind, but I feel like I'll invent them. One of them is that it is not thought of as a product. It is an internal system that you're trying to, because it is also a solution other people.
Andrew Bailey: might use, and so when you're not committed to that, it's really just a break in step. That's issue number one. None of these are insurmountable issues, but it will be a good way for us to separate what is a product thing and what is the way you want to operate your business, and so you build something and you add to that in a product that it's not really something you want. The second thing is, if I have little kids and we have Duplo LEGOs, if I tell them to build a boat or a car or a plane, they pretty much all look the same because those LEGOs are too big for them to be that big.
Andrew Bailey: Until you get a really good LEGO set, which has really small LEGOs, it's really hard to really know. Oh, it's a house. No, Dad, it's a tank. It's a yacht. Right. And so, I think that some of the powerful things about Salesforce, the infrastructure that supports it, and some of the difficulties with Salesforce is... It's like building these Lego blocks. And so some of the ways that things have had to be pieced together,
Andrew Bailey: and sometimes you're forced into certain naming styles, it's because you're not actually getting an intricate, small, perfect, designed Lego. You're actually getting this kind of system that plays into it. The power of that is this, the limitation is that. So we're gonna, I think that when we hear what you're talking about, we're gonna hear some things that are related to trying to put block process into a product. That's a decision that's not ours to make, but it's a vote us to make. We're trying to help discern what makes it so complicated.
Andrew Bailey: What's a constraint of using a large Lego set, a Lego set that's not designed for that level of detail. Then just understanding, so if we can kind of see those, we'll kind of, maybe we'll circle it, maybe we'll mark them with something. We've got some colors, we have some options. I'm just telling you that in all of our thinking, and even yesterday, a little caught up, you know, kind of like simple and straightforward that was, coming. into this saying, okay, this is where everybody's talked about the pain points, and this is.
Andrew Bailey: where, when I say the word nervous, it was more like I needed a word to help you know that a pause goes slow and methodical, and then find the right categories that allow us to point to opposites, a decision point, we should, we will see this pattern repeating itself. Does that make sense? So, I think, unless it opens anybody's intuition, if the other discerners, galvanized wonders,
Andrew Bailey: wonders, whatever, just feels like if we pick a starting point, walk through a little, willing to go through a little slower, we tried to rush a little bit here, we probably didn't need to, right, go a little slow, and then try to see.
Sam Binder: Are you looking to kind of like yesterday, this is current state, what this team is doing, and we're staying there, we're not focusing on like skill.
Andrew Bailey: We're not focusing on that. Because right now we don't even know what the thing is. But if, and especially learning here, I know at least in the beginning, the goal of future state is for it to behave like a product, which is to be intuitive, to reach expectations with other tools that you use. And so that's sort of ingrained in our thinking. And so it's not that I want to do that, but I think right at this beginning step, we're going to be a little more focused on state and state.
Andrew Bailey: And then, because I think we need to come to these next conversations prepared to say, here are some options. You may or may not have thought how to do this, given right now somebody has to decide on a direction, and we want to at least be prepared. to give them more information about some ways that we could decouple without maybe thinking of it as just this or that. Maybe there's a three, a third, or a fourth, transitionary option, I'm not sure. I just feel like we need to, does that make sense.
Steve Muniak: Just to, they forgot to introduce themselves. Andy, who's our swami, Nate, who's our coder, I'm sorry, and Jake, our PM. And if you wanna really remember, write down Jake, white shirt, Nate, black shirt, because you're gonna get two nerds confused. Andy stands on his own. Fair enough. What's that? That's a mystic term for something like a guru.
Sam Binder: That's so funny, I.
Andrew Bailey: I always say I'm the most willing to sound dumb in front of you. Many have tried. Okay, so I. I feel like somebody from the block team. feels like they can coordinate with, and sort of build this out. Because I kind of want to try being an observer that points and slows things down.
Andrew Bailey: Because I believe I know what I'm talking about, but I think that sometimes I skip that. Does that make sense? Do you want to see it on the screen? Or do you want to lock it up? I think a screen would be really helpful.
Jake Herwaldt: I think a screen would be helpful. One person on the screen, maybe. Maybe help people up. Let's move this into the corner. I want to be okay starting slow and building. I'll shoot into it.
Vikki Dipple: Erica or Allie, do one of you want to play? We did get it.
Jake Herwaldt: We stole a cord from it.
Vikki Dipple: Erica should do it. Yeah. So we're just going to throw you right in there.
Erica Smith: Are you ready to go? We probably do. Sam, I'm going to order you a new laptop.
Erica Smith: I need a new battery.
Steve Muniak: Sam, all I'm trying to do is this. It's fine, it's fine. I love it, it's my favorite. Alright, so who's got the...
Vikki Dipple: Yeah, that guy. That will plug into Eric.
Jake Herwaldt: And you want to...
Vikki Dipple: Or at least she can put her computer over there and...
Andrew Bailey: So, here's something we've realized, or that we try to tell people who are domain experts. We don't know what the words you say mean.
Vikki Dipple: Talk to you like you're bad.
Andrew Bailey: Yeah, and sometimes it's just the speed. Sometimes it's like, I can catch up on that last sentence, oh yeah, they said that. But some of the sentence constructions, like, I know exactly what that sentence means, but I'm behind because I have to admit to your context right away. It was okay for this one, because I often say, I'm going to let it go fast, and I'm going to try to catch up, and I had the videos, and I was like, I think I can catch up by the end of the day, and I'll make that decision, and I can do it enough times.
Andrew Bailey: Today, I'm going to be a little bit more like, hold on a second.
Vikki Dipple: Yeah, you said a what.
Andrew Bailey: And it's not because you said it wrong. It's not because anything is that. It's because I think that this, us having a, there's no way that we can be helpful in some of these conversations later this week unless we really see, we're used to all of what you're going to explain to us. We know what it's like to build tools that make this sort of process faster. We know what it's like to have a product.
Vikki Dipple: I thought about that yesterday, actually. Because I'm an after-process. So I go through conversations that we have five times a week. But that was one of those things that came up was today, instead of saying our normal acronyms or, you know, a part request, it's not actually a part request in here. And then when you see it in here, you're going to be expecting. I might have a part request. Where's the part request? I don't know.
Vikki Dipple: And like we struggle with that we've been working in this system for two years and then to try and explain it to somebody else We have to remember to slow down and say the things that are actually here.
Andrew Bailey: I mean some of this is what we do. We're used to coming into somebody else's domain But what we often find I would say almost a hundred percent of the time we slow down we map things out We show a picture and, Nine times out of ten people are like, I never thought, you know, I didn't see it like that It's typically because they know so much we had this sort of dumb it down.
Jake Herwaldt: Okay, so what's the goal? Erica's going to drive. Yeah. We're just going to start. We're going to be our whiteboard drivers. I'll score. Are you sure? I bet you are. I think it could be good for making some block people. Okay, I'd like to make some block people.
Vikki Dipple: I'm a lefty, so my handwriting is going to go.
Andrew Bailey: I might do that, but my handwriting is going to go a little bit. All right. Sam, can I just ask? You talk so fast. That's true. And you know so much. Just don't be mad at me if I just say, can we slow that down.
Sam Binder: Oh, yeah. I'll never be mad at you. Okay. Wait, I have to talk? What? I'm sorry. What am I doing.
Jake Herwaldt: You're going to help us. I'll equip you with stuff. You stand.
Andrew Bailey: The goal is that we have the simplest. Okay. We're going to start.
Jake Herwaldt: like a flow yes like what we did yesterday but we're hoping you can and then this will be helpful to see yes but this will help okay okay i just wanted to call out as well obviously.
Jordan Clark: we're talking about internal fire yeah but the very early starting of this a lot of times, is the fsc workflow we were talking about and i feel strongly we should start with the fsc oh.
Jake Herwaldt: okay yeah let's start with that yeah what's the current process for that and you're probably the.
Sam Binder: most for like housing how high no what's important is this like could be a call it could be a i will.
Erica Smith: i will go through all the different variants. So the FSC will reach out to us, and we very rarely get a phone call, but that's usually.
Erica Smith: from the driving two hours to my next site, and I don't have to sit and try to send you an email, because yes, we still do emails, you aren't supposed to be, and then Chatter through Salesforce.
Andrew Bailey: Chatter is the internal Salesforce messaging.
Erica Smith: So what will happen is an engineer, and this isn't a perfect world, at least by what we have right now, that perfect world is going to change, but it's going to be perfect if I'm being fair with you guys, because we have a lot of, if you from the beginning. I had one engineer that we take on events private about two years now we, managed to sneak into conversation with him you know you could you should.
Erica Smith: chatter us through Salesforce so we can work on that because he didn't have the information he didn't have it right there with him and he's like I know like we'll just chatter us from the SR or the requisition whichever way and, he's like oh I don't Salesforce isn't for me I'm like I'm sorry what he's like yeah I don't I don't do sales that's not right I'm like I'll put a pin in that conversation I'll come back to you on that so you know so let me we have a lot.
Erica Smith: of engineers don't have that mentality of Salesforce isn't for the mobile right.
Andrew Bailey: there are.
Erica Smith: It is, but what he is saying is, I don't have to learn because I don't have to do it. That's what he's saying. Because he's one of the ones that emails in all of his requests.
Sam Binder: Okay, so email is not the ideal scenario. The ideal scenario is chatter. So the ideal scenario is, if you're an FSC and you have a part you need, what is the best thing to do.
Erica Smith: What they should be doing, and I know it's accomplishable because a lot of our engineers do it this way, is that they are issued SRV for every time that they have to go out and visit. Which is a service request visit. And that's a record in Salesforce. Yes, that's a record in Salesforce off of the SR that was opened for that piece of equipment.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: An SR is service request. So a visit is created off of a service request, which that usually comes through the call center originally.
Erica Smith: It comes through the disk.
Andrew Bailey: And this, for greater context, is kind of the beginning of block with service, servicing things. Right. When parts was a long time ago, obviously, and then servicing parts both grew and got.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: Right. So, like, a site calls in, says our MRI is down, that comes into our call center. The call center creates a service request in Salesforce. If then it's determined that an engineer needs to go on site, then an SRV is created, so a service request visit, and then if that engineer needs a specific part for that site, that's when they're chattering on the SRV, and that's when we roll it over to them. Right? So there's a little change to that, but yes.
Andrew Bailey: Hold on. Don't worry about it. Don't need to write anything down right now. Let's just absorb for a second. First off, I'm pretty sure we're pre-anything we're talking, because this doesn't have anything to do with parts, but it's okay for context. True? Yeah. Okay.
Sam Binder: and we're trying with the idea of like giving the engineers an easier way of.
Andrew Bailey: getting this information right we've talked about that yeah which I like knowing it because it is because I we would say we might say hey we think this is a really great way to keep worlds aligned for now but I just wanted to yeah okay the how does this the FSC know that they've been given a visit do they get an email first or do they have to go into Salesforce to get it they so if.
Erica Smith: the way that Salesforce is set up to my knowledge is that I will think most pieces of equipment kind of like a layered this is the first this is the first engineer you have the secondary and maybe a tertiary I don't think we have any engineers to have a tertiary but it's primary second so it should automatically, to the engineer, and he'll get a notification in his email saying, you've been assigned to this.
Andrew Bailey: So the email is something, so Salesforce is saying, hey, you've been assigned. Well, somebody tells Salesforce there's a problem, Salesforce emails that person. That's probably one reason why they don't think they have to go to Salesforce, because their first point of contact is an email. They're like, no, I'm not a person. And Salesforce on mobile looks like three-year-old artwork.
Erica Smith: It is. It's hard.
Andrew Bailey: So they get an email, but that's what, do they, does the email tell them everything they need to know.
Erica Smith: I'm going to try to find one so you can see it.
Sam Binder: And this is an SRV that launches a notification to the engineer.
Andrew Bailey: I don't know about you guys, but one of my favorite things is nested emails. It's just one of my passions in technology. Has there been a better solution.
Erica Smith: I hate conversations. I don't so this is this is the engineer that goes this is the email that goes out to the engine says we've scheduled a new services it for you here's the details which is usually the contact person and their phone number the address the SRV which is what their assignment is based off of on the SR.
Erica Smith: that was created you know it says hey you need you to be there on the 3rd 11, 11 11 a.m. that's kind of what the customer has said when they call it and say hey we're having an issue our system will be available at 11 o'clock 1130 won't be available to 3 whatever the contact center information from car and, we just you know it pulls the generic information.
Erica Smith: of this system type the serial number some of these don't know what the effect code means i'm assuming they're probably the same thing that siemens used to preface i was a siemens employee before i came of block employee i was part of that acquisition partnership transition so i was doing on the siemens side so the effect code is probably just the same thing it's the.
Erica Smith: severity of the call so it does give them a lot of information about it it'll tell them um it's a monitor issue just what they're um so this is this is what the engineer gets when that.
Andrew Bailey: srv has been dispatched out so back it up and make it into a line some part goes down some piece of equipment goes down that hospital does have to, The most common is they phone a customer service person.
Erica Smith: Yes. So there is a tag on the system that has the block call center number along with the FF to identify what system they're calling.
Andrew Bailey: Then that block, CSR, customer service representative, creates the service request. As soon as they receive the phone call, I would imagine.
Erica Smith: Yes, they're opening it.
Andrew Bailey: Regardless of what the outcome is, even if it could be fixed virtually or legally.
Erica Smith: Yes, everything gets a finesse.
Andrew Bailey: Yep.
Erica Smith: Everything.
Andrew Bailey: And then at some point it's determined that a visit's required.
Erica Smith: Mm-hmm.
Andrew Bailey: And so they are also, whether it's that phone call or follow-up, they're going to create from there, they're going to create the visit.
Erica Smith: Yes, the SR card.
Andrew Bailey: And that is going to immediately trigger an email that goes to somewhere in there. Did a human decide which person there, or is there a person assigned to that geographic location.
Erica Smith: Well, there's a person, there's an engineer. assigned to each piece of equipment oh every piece of equipment should be you know that's.
Andrew Bailey: an appropriate and that's that's a sales force 360 that's when you guys when a piece of equipment comes under blocks service authority yes they are going to go through each one each one is that a big task i mean a hospital's got to have hundreds of pieces yeah okay so somebody goes through and says all right this is it does a does a service field service engineer know like i i am responsible for 922 pieces of equipment um i mean they have a general roundabout i don't know if they know an.
Erica Smith: exact number but they know that they were hired on to be a g ultrasound engineer and they know that the system or the facility has x okay just guess advantage was how many how many assets too damn many i mean i do believe it's up in the tens of thousands.
Steve Muniak: Yeah, and that's typical for a large RDN.
Erica Smith: That goes from Oregon all the way down to Hawaii.
Andrew Bailey: Oh, but Black does service work all over, right.
Erica Smith: Yes, that's just one customer.
Andrew Bailey: Okay, gotcha. So Black's total... We are coast to coast. We almost never care about a specific number. It's always a order of magnitude. Is it tens of thousands? Hundreds? Okay, so I'm going to skip over the very interesting problem of assigning field service engineers their capabilities. Yeah, that's not in the sculpture. I know, but I'm just telling you that Andy's brain likes that, because it feels like a magic trick that Andy must have built, but we're not going to do it.
Andrew Bailey: I just want you guys to know that I'm being a trained adult. Because I want to get to this spot. They've now received their email because... Somebody called, they received an email. The email gives them all the information, but it does not require them to go to Salesforce at this point.
Erica Smith: At this point, no, it does not.
Andrew Bailey: All right, cool. So they get there, they fix it, but while they get there, they identify, this needs a part. Then they're supposed to, this is where we have our first deviation, because they're supposed to, in the Salesforce 360, request a part.
Erica Smith: Let me backtrack just a little bit. But actually, I do believe that they have to accept the assignment, so it will take them.
Jake Herwaldt: Okay. If you don't do that, it's going to turn into a secondary person.
Erica Smith: Gotcha. Yes, so sitting here.
Andrew Bailey: They are actually, they're getting on Salesforce. At least minimal.
Erica Smith: Yeah.
Andrew Bailey: Would you guys, do you guys want that to be a button they do in that email? I'm not saying we're doing it. I'm just teasing. it was like good i mean obviously we have a lovely relationship i mean yeah i mean listen listen all your hopes and dreams are possible i just need to understand it um so like chicken scotch i'm sorry yeah yeah i love it i'm probably not the right person no no you're the perfect person for this sam you're the best so okay they've accepted it they they show up how do they what are the are.
Erica Smith: there two or three ways that they get parts um two to three just depending um there's three total options there is the rarity of a phone call phone there is an email or there is hey we've been to site or we've talked to the customer we know what we need and they go to their parts management and, they put the parts that they need in the in sales in sales.
Andrew Bailey: Do they have access to your sales force.
Erica Smith: They have access to sales force, yes.
Sam Binder: But that lives on what part management.
Erica Smith: The SR. The SR slash SRV.
Sam Binder: Okay, so they go to the site first. So they accept the site visit, then they go to the site, they physically are there.
Erica Smith: Or they call. One or the other. So they either are going to go to site or they can call, depending on what the issue is. They can call. Like for this one, for Rick. They can call and talk to the tech and say, hey, what's going on with your monitor? And most likely, Rick and Sherman, you either need a new cable or you need a new monitor without having to actually go. They can work through tech support with either, I know some of them do FaceTime calls, they do a lot of text messaging, conversation like that. So it's not always a site visit, but it's still because any kind of engineering is being done, it's still an SRV.
Andrew Bailey: Yeah, we're going to call this just brilliant engineering. It's going to be brilliant. And. But at some point, they recognize that parts need to be purchased or used to fix it. And so you said that they can either, when they're calling, they're calling headquarters or somebody employed with a block email address.
Erica Smith: They're calling one of us on the procurement team.
Andrew Bailey: Okay, one of the four procurements. Or they're emailing one of the four.
Erica Smith: So they're either calling one of the four, or they're emailing our inbox, or they're chattering us from the, that they have created.
Jake Herwaldt: What's the correct thing.
Erica Smith: They should be doing it through Salesforce. But you don't have a rec yet. No, they chatter us when they have uploaded their parts into the basket. They are to be chattering parts in basket, updated. On the screen, Erica, could you show them on the screen.
Steve Muniak: And Erica, you are not doing any part ID on this? No. They have to come to you with parts or go find it.
Erica Smith: No, we have to, we have to. quite frequently remind them that we are not PartsID. You can't send us a picture and try to get us to determine what that part number is. That has to go either, you either need to call, anybody within our tech support, and if our tech support cannot assist you, you need to have a call in with the OEM PartsID to figure out what it is.
Sam Binder: So why are they calling, emailing, or chattering if they can just add the P to the basket and create the record? Do you want the political answer or do you want the real answer? I want to know what they should be doing. They're lazy, it's true laziness. That's what I thought, I just wanted to like.
Erica Smith: Some uneducatedness, but it's true laziness.
Sam Binder: So there's a lack of potentially understanding, right.
Erica Smith: Willing, I don't know that I'd say lack of, I'd say there's a, there's willing of understanding. We have engineers that, I wasn't kidding when I said, he's like, oh, I don't use Salesforce.
Sam Binder: So what they should do to save you an extraordinary amount. is to just add the parts they need to the basket which creates the requisition.
Erica Smith: which fires off everything that we've been well so not quite so they add the parts of the basket and that's submitting they put them in the basket and they will chatter us okay so you would have no idea that a basket with.
Sam Binder: parts has been created if they don't chatter you there's no automation yeah.
Jake Herwaldt: when you're thinking about is this a little like one big basket where I can put like can you put three different orders like how would how do you know that for that engineer needs to go to that place because you have to you have to do it against the so that goes with cool so there isn't a visit is it why I'll go basket auto trigger basket.
Jake Herwaldt: I want you to know that let's not spend too much time on this because we can't modify this. I know. I wish you could. I know you want to. No, no, no, I'm not even trying to do that.
Andrew Bailey: I'm just trying to understand. So the part gets in the basket and now, now like whether they did it through phone, email, chatter, let's, let's just put it, all three of those get to the point where now you're doing your, your sourcing. So you look at it, all right, show me, is it, is there something you can show us that's active or not active? I don't know.
Sam Binder: what you're allowed to show us. What happens when you've been chatted and the part's in the basket.
Erica Smith: Now take over. I was actually looking at one of you two to be like, what can I tell them. I'm pretty sure. Because I will talk if you tell me I can talk. So unfortunately it is a, looks like it's a little bit of a, I don't want to say what it is. but it's a little bit of a slow morning, so I don't have, like, one that I can show you right off.
Vikki Dipple: Say that again? Could you show an example and play around with it.
Erica Smith: I honestly don't know. I don't even know if I still have access to SaneBlock. I don't use it. I don't have a link for it. I don't know that I ever actually got it because of my transition time was when it was right supposed to go live, and then it didn't, and it got pushed to January, and I wasn't really in any of that. But what happens is, you know, we'll call it perfect world. The engineer put their basket, and they'll chatter us, so we acknowledge it, saying, hey, we're working on that,
Erica Smith: and we submit the hard basket to create a reference.
Sam Binder: And that's done by your team.
Erica Smith: That should be. done by our team. It's still an option for the engineer to do that and that's where some of the handholding coming how many times we don't do that just do this but I couldn't really go down that line waste a good hour. So that requisition is tied to the service visit or the service? Both.
Steve Muniak: tied well it's tied to the SR. So Eric is just like the perfect world for you is going to go, into that put their parts in into the basket at that point they they press some button and.
Erica Smith: drop your buckets. No so we don't have a queue yet. We do not have a queue like the three yards. I say supposedly I don't know what the status of that is it's been working on. I know that it is an open topic of conversation with the force medic team. created. Cole could probably provide a better approach as she could be with our meeting today, but that's what we're going towards is having a queue, but right now it truly just comes in like...
Sam Binder: They don't know about the basket. What's that? They don't know what they're... the care team doesn't know.
Erica Smith: there's anything in the basket until they're chattered. Yeah, so we don't have any kind of notification if we don't get.
Sam Binder: chatter. And then they're the ones that press the button that turn it into a recognition.
Andrew Bailey: So literally all you're doing is log on and saying, okay, go source. Just to give you guys a box for this, this is one of those, this is the Duplo box thing. This is Salesforce comes with a lot of superpowers and it comes with limitations. These are the limitations. Why does it take so long? Well, it's because superpowers, in this case, these like very, these blocks come with a lot of infrastructure that allows certain things to be done more quickly and certain things to not be able to be done. So I don't want to get overly distracted. If we want to categorize this as like,
Andrew Bailey: Hey, We've got no, there's this manual process of even identifying that a basket exists, or a manual process of doing this. We can put that, but that is the size of the Lego we're working. And so, I do this, because I want to get to the part where you're now, and tell me if I should slow down and get into that, but I want to push us past that.
Sam Binder: I would just say, does every, does it need a human involvement to discern the parts of this basket need to be a requisition? So, they put the parts in the basket, but you, What do you do to create the actual requisition? You're creating the requisition, but why? Like, why doesn't that requisition already get, Because we don't, so, Is there times where you don't ever want to get that part, even though the parts are in the basket.
Erica Smith: No, the problem is, is that if the engineers, and this is actually something that has recently changed, but if the engineers are the ones, and they click the do not auto-source button, they'll get all the conversations.
Sam Binder: So you're doing that because you don't trust the engineer's gonna do it right.
Erica Smith: No, it's not that they're not gonna do it right. She needs all the notifications. We need all the notifications, that are coming from the vendors.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: Yeah, because if the engineer created the red.
Andrew Bailey: She needs to put the downstream. So she's the owner.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: The problem is though, is that's not working.
Andrew Bailey: But still, this is Lego block issue again.
Erica Smith: To answer your question, yes. Yes, even if we are the ones who push the button, it is still going to do that. We don't know when that changed, but that changed and it has caused havoc in our world.
Sam Binder: Okay, so let's say it all works fine. You create the requisition from the service request. You say do not.
Erica Smith: No, we want it to source. If the engineer, because they don't listen and they have to push all the buttons. push the button because they don't have somebody there holding their hand they like to just push all the buttons until it's done they're supposed to click the do not autosource button because at one point in time that would allow us to go in and manually source it so we were getting the notification but in a.
Sam Binder: perfect world the notifications would work yes and you would want it to automate into sourcing window you'd want it to follow the flow that it would follow if you didn't have to make it stop correct I mean it would it would.
Erica Smith: follow the normal I mean I say normal not be normal to everybody but you know you submit the requisition and then it automatically sources out to tier one.
Andrew Bailey: and so we'll start so this is where you guys have a Salesforce to sourcing window integration we were actually wrestling with this legendary built the current sourcing window 2.0.
Sam Binder: They did, but they wouldn't change anything for us that broke, so then we had to come in and modify, but then that really bastardized the whole thing, so now Legendary doesn't support their parts.
Andrew Bailey: That's a good use of that word. There's no central owner.
Sam Binder: No one wants to own it anymore, and so we're struggling with the multiple hands in the bucket.
Andrew Bailey: Everybody's like, well, that's their thing.
Sam Binder: And the massive notification issues we're having is kind of in part to that.
Andrew Bailey: Right, so this is, so it becomes a requisition at the point where it becomes a, this is where, this is that, this is the second problem. So you really touched on the first one, which is using the Lego blocks. Does that analogy make sense? Okay, I get to use a fat Lego block rather than a bunch of little ones, so it speeds up some things, but because I use a fat Lego block, I can't really see that this is supposed to be the curvature of a ship. Alright, cool. That's a good analogy.
Andrew Bailey: So this is a direct, this is where you both your fat Lego block and block building a tool for themselves that turned into a useful tool for other companies or becomes, the tool becomes much more powerful when there's more participation. And the, I don't want to say lack of commitment to it becoming a product, but it's slow maturation into a product. I would say current sourcing window, if I'm being real honest, is not actually a product sourcing window 2.0 is not a product, right?
Andrew Bailey: Because it's not differentiated from the tool that block and block has to make a decision about what that looks like. Lots of things are possible. I'm not saying anything's impossible, so much as possible, but there will have to be clear lines and whatever becomes a product is going to be incredibly easy to use functional, very design driven and user experience driven and very consistent experiences. And it's going to just. Be an incredible tool because no, it's not a product if it's not incredible, a tool just. This makes other things easier, but it doesn't have to be great.
Andrew Bailey: We've made a bunch of tools that are for our own team, but if somebody else tried to use that tool, they'd be like, what is going on? And that's what happens, right? When you get the mix of the two, it's like, well, which one is which? So right here is our first intersection that I can see of where you try to have this product, pull these records and auto source and do all the things. I'm not saying it's a bad thing, but it's a blocked tool now interfacing with our product, idea. And we're using Lego blocks.
Andrew Bailey: Cool. We're there. What at this point? So the tiers start, that's an internal behind the scenes algorithm that says release to this tier, release to this tier. What do you get notified? What happens.
Steve Muniak: Can I interrupt for a second? Vendor tiering applies both to the buy and the sell side.
Sam Binder: No, only internal. Okay. So we don't tier vendors for SOEP customers.
Steve Muniak: Oh, that's right. It's only for, but if we're sourcing, let me re-ask the question.
Sam Binder: Sure.
Steve Muniak: Vendor tiering just applies to any sourcing, sourcing to purchase or resale or sourcing to consign.
Sam Binder: Correct, unless, this is like in the weeds, but unless when Chute said the do not auto-source button is clicked, it stops the tiering, and then the CSR is looking at, we've broken down the sourcing groups. There's a little tab that you could, I don't know if you'd care to see, a little tab that says here's all of your approved vendors for this modality manufacturer, and then they can actually say, I only want to go to these two vendors because I know this guy has it, this is my friend. So manual sourcing can override the tiers. Otherwise, automations are in place for everything.
Steve Muniak: I'm going down the system because there's a line that we need to, there's going to be approved vendors within sales for that, and then there are going to be a different set of vendors, direct within sales for that. it's going to be really really asking is this a direct is this a shared vendor so the system will.
Vikki Dipple: know based on the account yeah of request so if the account block is the one that's sourcing it will know to auto source to direct tier one if common spirit puts through the request and they're the ones that initiated the sourcing it will automatically with no tier involved even though.
Sam Binder: and for procurement there is no direct connect differentiation just for that and the reason i.
Steve Muniak: bring this up also then confusing going to be those then those vendor records all are all part of the vendor so that vendor can be, It's your vendor, but it all lives in that vendor master.
Andrew Bailey: We love tables.
Sam Binder: That's a good call-out.
Sam Binder: Back to vendor.
Andrew Bailey: We, can I, I need to pause for two minutes and ask a direct question just so I understand. I just want to make sure we're getting everybody. You three have been silent today. Is this because it's mostly your expertise.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: I don't deal in that world at all. I don't deal in that world. I'm the only one that deals in this world.
Andrew Bailey: Okay, I just want to make sure because otherwise I want to be like, hey, I need you guys to either jump in more or do whatever, but I'm okay. So the next thing. Stuck with me.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: You're stuck with Erica.
Andrew Bailey: I had a video. I was actually like, is this too good to be true? Yesterday, Allie made me feel real dumb as she was drawing all these lines. She's like, Andy, did you get it? I was like, no, but I got my aid did.
Jake Herwaldt: These three could go over external buy-in. Is that something? Oh, yeah. split it off into two is that i don't know is that there's going to be i mean right i i could.
Andrew Bailey: yeah we're about to go where we're about to go everybody now here's what i want to try and do because yesterday steve yelled at me yesterday i tried to have everybody work six straight hours without a break um because we were being hardcore i was trying to match sam's intensity i would say nobody can do that yeah well i tried and okay here i am i would like to give you guys maybe um uh like 20 minutes i'm not really going to interrupt i want you guys to take us through.
Andrew Bailey: this this next phase and i'm just going to watch i want you to i want to try that and then we're going to take a break and we're going to i'm going to see if letting you guys fight through how would you explain this to us knowing what we know the current state how would you how would you line it up i'm going to try to not slow you down because i'm just kind of trying, methods of getting the workflow out there.
Erica Smith: How detailed do you, like, how dumbed down do you be? Are you a five-year-old, or are you an educated? I'm an educated person.
Andrew Bailey: and I'm ramping up on your domain.
Vikki Dipple: Do you need a timer to keep yourself accountable? Because when you said 20 minutes, my mind was like.
Andrew Bailey: I once earned my high school classroom a movie by the quiet of 20 minutes.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: Siri set a timer for 20 minutes. And you remembered it to this day. I remember.
Andrew Bailey: they were like, that's why we got to watch Braveheart. That tells you how rare that is. Yeah, my teacher's like, you can just shut up for 20 minutes. We will watch Braveheart next time. Now I'm convinced we're going to watch.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: Braveheart. Well, you've already used 10 seconds.
Andrew Bailey: Yeah, sorry. Okay, so I'm not going to say, we're not going to say anything. And you, if you ask us a direct question, like, do you guys get that, then I will say yes or no, but I'm going to watch. And then we'll take a doctor's question. Yes, I'm going to watch that. Okay, so we're at the point.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: where now the rec is made and it's sourcing. Yes, so it goes out.
Erica Smith: by tiers. It starts with our first tier. Sam, you'll have to remind me, if it doesn't get a response within, from, is it two vendors? Yeah, so two vendors in 15 minutes, it'll go down to this tier. It'll continue to do the same through the third tier. The fourth tier, you have to manually go in, add those vendors fresh in. There are times where I'll go in and just, if I've looked at the historical sourcing,
Erica Smith: I'll go ahead and just start sourcing to ones that I know we've historically gotten pricing from, even if it's the second and third tier down, and I just position. I don't always wait because I don't have time.
Sam Binder: So just to jump on that, that's a really big differentiator with procurement because timing is so much more important. Not that it's like the other teams. They need to PO out now. Sometimes it's not the best price. It's the fastest response, fastest time they can chip part. And because of that, they often jump over. the automations to get their answers faster by manually sourcing instead of waiting for those tiers to kick in on those intervals that we've like waiting.
Sam Binder: 45 minutes for to the third tier is not acceptable sometimes I think the best.
Erica Smith: way that I've described it to some of the team that has come over from the parts team to the procurement team is this is completely different lines that you're looking through for the parts team you are you're trying to sell a part and you offer your best pricing and it's then on the customer and if the customer goes then they bite they bite if they don't you do your follow-up but that's kind of about it I'm not trying to dumb down what you know by any stretch It's fine Erica. Just trying to look at like the very broad.
Erica Smith: I used to sell to Erica for two years Longer than that Just that's a very broad description of what it is for us we are trying to do multiple things in a very short period of time, We're trying to look at the best quality, look for the best pricing. For some of us, warranty is a factor. Can I get it from a vendor for a couple bucks more that has a better warranty? Sure. Also, can this ship out today? A lot of what we're doing is critical. They needed a yesterday kind of situation,
Erica Smith: so we need to ensure that it's going to show up the next business day, either by 8.30 or 10.30, if it's not going out on shipment. NFL means next flight out, and it's its own.
Sam Binder: level of urgency that trumps everything. How often is that? Every day. Multiple tests.
Unknown: a day, every day. Percentage-wise, 15% of all. Oh, okay. You go a couple days without.
Erica Smith: it. Not in their world. Not in our world. We have multiple daily. Becca, just last night alone, in the span of two hours, had three NFOs that came in. every second counts. It truly does every second truly counts so we don't necessarily have time to wait for it to hit the tiers which is to Sam's point why we manually go ahead and search a source.
Steve Muniak: Just to confirm Erica, do you guys really have discretion over when that final part selection is presented.
Erica Smith: Yes, you guys would wouldn't you? Is it you guys that kind of determined to say hey this is the best one to do or they've been on that side of the business but I know ours was different ours was different than I.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: think the way as far as options yeah and there's a lot of gray probably in the parts world because there's probably certain customers for instance like I'm not going to source, certain vendors for certain customers either based on feedback quality like if GE MVS is asking for a part I'm probably not going to get it from Debbie Cole knowing that yeah there's that or we also selectively sourced based on GE.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: for instance is so well connected I'm not going to probably I'm not going to go to direct med because they're already going yeah so there's there's quality issues where I'm not going to even if Debbie Cole or BMX x-ray like quotes me and something that I'm sourcing for GE sometimes I'll still say unavailable because I don't want to deal with the headache of it possibly not being a high-quality part where I may take more of a risk like for an international customer or like a 626s type person.
Erica Smith: yeah yeah that's what I was gonna say yeah it's like hard dog I remember one of the like the questions that went out on homework was you know that insider knowledge and our vendor and their quality yeah that's yeah yeah when I was.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: selling to Erica sometimes she like is this coming from so-and-so because if so.
Erica Smith: I don't want so that is definitely part of like that in that internal Intel that it's it's one of those things that you can't teach you just it's something you.
Vikki Dipple: have to learn and build that experience so I'm so sorry I thought I could do.
Andrew Bailey: that I can't do we made it six and a half do you think that the data would show who it's here for is or is it experience that shows up here for meaning experience because I think quality is, We have more than enough data to have tiered approaches just based on, oh, this is how reliable they've been, this is how...
Aly Boggs-Smitley: So we use, like, so that's where we use the data from, like, your response time. If you're never in the tool and you're never responding to us, then you're probably not a customer or a vendor that we want in the tool if you're not actually going to use it and we constantly have to either call you to get a response. There's, we keep track of your DOA rate, so if you have a really high DOA rate or cosmetic issues or anything like that... Or you just become difficult to work with. Or you just become difficult to work with, yeah. So there's, like, the bad part of, like, tier four.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: However, there are people that are in tier four that aren't necessarily bad vendors, but let's say it's just, like, he's an, it's an engineer that's by himself that sometimes parts out a couple systems. He doesn't want the hundreds of requests that we get every day. He's literally a, I have to call you and see if you have this because you are only parting out a couple systems at once. They're not in all parts. That has a team, like, a giant team quoting you and all this. Like a key player. It's a big inventory. Yeah.
Sam Binder: Yeah, it's him and him alone. Right. You always have an overlap of the tricky bit with DOA, which is the driver of data, is that if you have a vendor that's small, you may buy from them a couple times a month. They get one bad part, and their DOA rate is inappropriately off the charts and correct, and it looks like they're the worst vendor in the world. They're not one DOA, but we don't buy from them enough to allow them to offset that.
Steve Muniak: If you're measuring DOA by dollar amount, it didn't even exacerbate that at all. That's how I understand these conversations all the time, that if you guys spike last quarter, we're going to be right.
Sam Binder: Right, because we looked at the data, and we saw it was because of...
Jake Herwaldt: Can I challenge us 45 minutes to try and document this as much as possible.
Sam Binder: So here's where I wanted some clarification. Everything that we've been talking about is a part of the block sourcing process, and was in videos, in requirements. Okay, so do you still want that up here, even though it's not a new process.
Jake Herwaldt: Is that it.
Sam Binder: Because I could simplify it and say, like, enter... the sourcing window process, or do we want to break down the process.
Jake Herwaldt: Look over this and tell me, this is like, no, I didn't pass this out because it's so simple. I just didn't know if this is like oversimplifying your process, internal. So then it's like, do you have the part? If you have the part, yes, great. Okay. Do it. If you don't, tear it and then wait and then be done. Is it that simple.
Erica Smith: Really? Yes. From a high level, yes. From a very high level, yeah. Okay.
Jake Herwaldt: I didn't pass this out because I'm like, it can't be that simple.
Vikki Dipple: That's just simple. Seeing it visually, having it written out for you guys, I think it's really important.
Jake Herwaldt: Okay. Let's pass that out then. I just didn't because I thought they were just too simple.
Jordan Clark: This is where I feel like you cannot understate the value of the API integration. Right. Because so many of the things that Eric and Ellie are talking about, obviously the quality comes into play in terms of conditions, but in the instance of like, well, I'm not going to ask this vendor because I know that this customer knows this vendor. Well, if I have a direct path to pricing regardless, let's quote it and let's let it ride. Let's try it out. Let's see what happens. So there's just so many more opportunities, and the speed of play for Erica's team would be...
Jake Herwaldt: When you look at this right here, this is where we're at. Not all three, just so it's clear.
Andrew Bailey: I want to step out just a step and then say, I wanted to do an analogy, but I don't know if I have a great analogy. We've currently been talking about the idea of sourcing window being a product, and then Salesforce being a core block source. And then trying to say, look at this, does it look like this? Right now, we know what it looks like.
Andrew Bailey: We're trying to say, well, what does it look like like this? And that might not be the best, right? And I'm just giving you some ideas of why it's good for us to hear the picture, because maybe it's saying, you know what? Our FSEs deserve a... Whenever we say product, what we mean is a... an easy-to-use solution, right, that is custom to them, that they're likely to want. A product is something somebody wants to use. At the end of the day, a product doesn't survive unless somebody wants to buy it.
Andrew Bailey: And buy it for an internal person means they want to change the way they do things because it's so much easier to do that. Whenever we as engineers build a tool internally, and we've got a bunch of people who are, some people have been at this job for 30 years, some people have been at this job one year, we would always build something, and then the people who have been there 30 years are like, ah, my way of doing it. We always knew we won when that person who had been there for 30 years had their own way, was like, I want to use that, right? That's the thing. And so that was internally, when we're building software, that was like, oh, we just made a product,
Andrew Bailey: not just a tool because people wanted to use it. It's sort of like, you can call it a product, but if nobody's buying it, then it has no market, right? And so we may, like, when I first heard this, it's like, oh, maybe the field service engineer needs their own. Very small in comparison product that allows them to participate perfectly this with your team not that you know, Scope and everybody's got to make decisions on that. That's another thing, but I'm just like let's extract that or that.
Andrew Bailey: Let's just say all right well That's frustrating it illuminates that this current solution is not functioning as a product because it's not earning people's time and Block hasn't currently been willing to use the stick to enforce it right, There's two things and I always say if you're not willing to use the stick to enforce it You don't really it doesn't really mean you're not willing to if you're not willing to invest in the solution That makes it easier. Just like well. Let's just deal with it sometimes. It's priority right you guys are people in the middle of exploding, Sometimes those are those aren't questions you want to would you think together thoughtfully?
Andrew Bailey: Transparency build trust all right, so uh-huh so do you want to see this process broken down.
Sam Binder: Or do you want to say like we know? the process enough to skip over the details, stay high level, and go to the next bit, where they're now uploading a purchase under the vendor and getting that part to their office.
Jake Herwaldt: Is the part that we're skipping over the pieces that we just talked about where it's like there's tier one which has an X bucket, then it goes to tier two, and then that's pretty.
Sam Binder: much all that's happening? Yep, there's like negotiating back and forth via chatter, there's.
Jake Herwaldt: the... Which is all the same as like an external buyer would do the same thing. Yes, and it's the.
Sam Binder: same exact process that the parts team would do, that the internal buying, all the same. There's basically this negotiation that happens. So this is a... So SRC records are created here, that's what ties in with the vendors and their experience. You're just doing it, one of you is.
Andrew Bailey: doing it in lightning.force.com and he is doing it in Sourcing Window. You're saying Future State.
Sam Binder: or currently? Currently. No, we're all doing it through Salesforce. There's no internal interaction.
Steve Muniak: between Allie's team. So the vendors are interacting in Sourcing...
Vikki Dipple: So what you see at the bottom of this page, like we showed yesterday, at the bottom, all of those SRCs connect, those are our internal side of the sourcing window that the vendors see as a portal.
Jake Herwaldt: And I think something Steve and I were just talking about that's, I think, important for, the internal buyer persona, the idea of this automating the, like, quoting is not a thing that they will ever assert or be like, hey, that's important for us. That means it's just completely out of scope. Yeah. Unless we try and rep. Yeah, unless. And it's a book for right now.
Jake Herwaldt: Correct me if I'm wrong in this statement. A person using this tool, an internal buyer, Erica, your team, thinks they're just in the, They don't think that they're in-source.
Erica Smith: No, we're in Salesforce.
Jake Herwaldt: Yeah.
Erica Smith: We look at this and go, this is Salesforce. Yeah.
Nathan Bedford: So, but we're saying this process is not ideal. So meaning like, yeah, just not separate, think about the current state, future state. I know in the video you were saying we might try to pull some of this out at some point. Yeah, that's the whole thing we're trying to figure out.
Sam Binder: Yeah, so if we were to say this is going to live in the sourcing window, we would have to have it look like this. So they're not leaving Salesforce, they're not leaving their processes, but the Rutgers would be, yeah.
Jake Herwaldt: Because the magic behind the scenes is Salesforce or is sourcing window.
Sam Binder: Currently it's Salesforce, future state, anything else.
Jake Herwaldt: It could be something, yeah. Do you see that? I mean, genuinely it could be an action that happens in Salesforce that triggers magic.
Nathan Bedford: Yeah. And sales. Why do you, and why do you guys say that it needs to stay in Salesforce? I'm just challenging, like it.
Sam Binder: And it doesn't need to stay in Salesforce. I think that, I don't know the language to say. The experience cannot feel like I have to go. I went to a different app.
Jake Herwaldt: No, but do you guys understand that part of the speech.
Nathan Bedford: I did hear that, and I'm just saying, if it was better than Salesforce, maybe they wouldn't mind going to another app.
Steve Muniak: And I wanna leave that option on the table, because definitely you can come in, outside of what's from Legendary and give us a different paradigm.
Andrew Bailey: And this is what I needed in marketing, one way. It is also, you guys, just a little bit ago, you were very small, and now you're four times bigger, and that's still, compared to a lot of companies, very small, it's much bigger than you were. Many companies that get this big, don't get the luxury of staying in line. There's financial service companies, you'll see them, and they have products that were issued in the 80s and 90s, and it's built on this GUI system,
Andrew Bailey: and then the 2000s, and it's on this system, and then products in the most recent state, and then sometimes they build one into, they're like, oh, we tried to build it all in one, and then it. falls apart and I'm like, oh, I'm not doing that again, right? It is very common to have different tools, and it's a luxury to try and stay in one, and I'm not even saying it's a bad thing, I'm just saying, I'm saying for us, and for the sake of, this is all the, when you do discovery, and you ask everybody to complain or show us all your stuff, and we're like, alright, our contract, which we never use, but just for the sake of conversation,
Andrew Bailey: is building source in window 3.0, which we've already realized is this, and it's like, whoa, whoa, what is this tool? I think we're just trying to understand, if asked the question, what do you guys recommend? It helps us to see, oh, well, what's important, what's essential, and then why? Why do you think it's so important to stay in one? And it's not.
Sam Binder: It's not. I would say it's not as long as the process is so streamlined that it's not a bump, another bump, because we have so many bumps. Let's not create another bump, but to what you said, if it is still a mind-blowing process that's going to speed up everything, sure, no one's going to care.
Andrew Bailey: We only deal, we don't, just imagine, we don't build software unless it's a product we don't build things unless when you use it you're like that made my life so much better if if we built something and you didn't say that then we.
Vikki Dipple: worked out yeah well i think one of the other important things to remember is that we want this tool to make the csr too small so that it is so automated and so easy and to have more opportunity to fight and negotiate with this big dollar sales that's really really focused on making the more money yeah and the procurement team doesn't have to spend so much time doing all this there's too.
Vikki Dipple: many here for it to be sustainable and we're old school like we still have the like trauma.
Sam Binder: of being told though here's your here's your other tool you have to copy and paste all the information you just did here and here and then we're like ah, Well, what you're saying is very different. There's another tool, but there's automations that will prevent you.
Andrew Bailey: It's not done until you're like, and that's not, that isn't like, oh, you get special treatment. That isn't, like, we're here. We could be hedging our bets right now. I'm telling you right now that the way that works, and we've seen your current state, the way that it's done when you guys are like, yeah. And because most of the wow that we see is like, well, that's sort of, there's no, like, that's not even, that's like the basics of building stuff. Okay. And I'm not, it's not being, I'm trying to understand where and why the limits exist.
Andrew Bailey: for some of the things that you guys deal with. If we're being, if we're coming in, it's like, why would we build this thing that's amazing? And then I have to know how to even talk to the rest of you guys. And how to talk to the other people. Yeah. Without saying, oh, yeah, we're just going to let that part be really awful continually.
Sam Binder: Because people are afraid.
Andrew Bailey: And if it's, if the issue is that, and I at least want to be able to say in all the meetings and say, Okay, well, if your goal is to slowly do things and mature and take a step and build trust with us and say, well, can you really do that? It's like, all right, well, then we will do that. Let's focus on getting that done. Let's see what that's possible because maybe that's the issue with knowing what phase two and phase three should be is because we just can't comprehend it being that smooth. And then, all right, well, let's make a little prototype of this mobile-based interactive system because whether the information is organized by something called Salesforce, whether it's called Salesforce, called Azure, called AWS,
Andrew Bailey: it's just data and it just needs, there are things behind the scenes that would make our life more difficult if the data is poorly organized. But that's not your call. That's not your issue, right.
Vikki Dipple: Yeah. I think having this as an external product. It's not a tool.
Vikki Dipple: It's a product.
Vikki Dipple: I think. It would be totally fine for blocking the amazing tool that is being built. We need to make sure That is the hesitancy of outside.
Jake Herwaldt: External buyer external vendor then start pulling slowly person by person like roll by roll if I'm being really honest.
Andrew Bailey: We're just saying that to you guys I mean that is true But we're saying that to you guys to make you guys feel better and understand most of the systems that we work on that literally tens of, Different things like this that all have to enter into an accounting team It is larger than that is 20 30 people and one person is, responsible for the feed into this system. That is so in our world, that we're able to build the beautiful thing without breaking the industrial thing. And I've been responsible for both the industrial thing.
Andrew Bailey: and the pretty thing on both sides, right? I'm the one who's like, hey, you can't break my industrial thing. Well, why not? Well, it's because it's 2 million lines of code and it runs on a $5 million machine that we have to release every year, right? Oh, okay. Why do you guys do that? Well, it's because it literally never breaks. The internet can, the world gets bunkered in, right? Or it's like, oh, I need to make this beautiful thing. They're like, hey, as long as you don't break my old thing, it'll work.
Steve Muniak: Okay, where are we at.
Andrew Bailey: I think we probably need to have a break. I'll just take it quick. Uh-huh.
Vikki Dipple: So we did a little bit, we had Salesforce, SAP.
Vikki Dipple: Now it's getting, I would love just. for them to say yes because it's so sourcing to like that amount of scale is.
Vikki Dipple: Put it out, you've seen it, but yeah.
Jake Herwaldt: It's not the end of the lead-up when we eventually, because that's kind of, I think that's essentially, what our pitch was, and then start as close, as similar to both buyers, with the idea.
Jake Herwaldt: The internal has this idea of this autosuggestive. If that's the old, it actually is. And if that's the new, I mean, not trivial, but it's like, then what you do is you have to, then you just basically say, oh, okay, for this special block, do this magic, that just basically all it's doing is automating what someone would do. And then eventually with the external vendor, it's the idea that like, when somebody looks.
Jake Herwaldt: up, when an external buyer, what is, they'll be able to say, oh, they're like this.
Erica Smith: I honestly, I wouldn't know what to say if there's something different. Yeah. Do you, would you say you said most.
Erica Smith: Most of them, I would say, are from Salesforce. I mean, we have a few, like, in Salesforce, but not in Salesforce. Like, the Shawn Mendes of the world, who, they're in Salesforce, and they show that they are users in Salesforce, but they don't ever feel like we're having...
Sam Binder: Can we not do that anymore? Because we're just, like... That would be great, but... We're feeding the...
Erica Smith: The problem is, is that we just, they have become...
Erica Smith: And so, a lot of it happens... I was reaching out, direct, all right. And then, this is, like... Yeah. Yeah, I've heard that before.
Unknown: I didn't know it was in here. I asked for a power strip.
Erica Smith: So, yeah, unfortunately, it's one of those that I don't, I think because, like, AIS is a vehicle, because it is a very small company, it's, I don't know if John and Willie and Wilson have run it, and I don't think that they have one, so I honestly think that's why, even though they're technically, um, people that, like, have a chair or something, a power block, I think they may be listening to it if they ever lose.
Sam Binder: They don't. They're total assholes. Um, they also, like, lie a lot. They're not my favorite vendors. Like, I've gone head-to-head with Sean a few times. We try not to talk to each other, unfortunately, and, um... I know you guys don't get a SAG, right? No, we don't. You really don't, but it's frustrating because we have... You are one of the three teams using sourcing window. And I've had conversations with Sean where he's like, I don't have to use it because I'll still get POs.
Sam Binder: And it's frustrating because Sean won. And it's like, but you'd get more POs if you used it because the only team willing to go above and beyond to get you orders.
Erica Smith: Honestly, he probably wouldn't. That's the thing. It's because his pricing is always high. But he has those in that... So why don't we just forward stock near certain areas.
Sam Binder: We just put one in major scale. I want to cut the legs off of Sean Wang. No, I would love to. Uh-huh.
Erica Smith: He's just like... He is. We have become a vending machine.
Andrew Bailey: So you guys used to fight, and now you guys have to be friends.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: No, it wasn't fighting. I just had to find everything that she needed. Before we got acquired by Siemens, we sold to Siemens.
Erica Smith: Yeah, so I kind of have an interesting perspective that is even more interesting than I've been on both sides of it. So I've been the buyer, buying through Block, and now I'm the buyer, buying through. But even down to that, our group, when I was with Siemens, was different than anybody else's. So I was like that. in the ass customer of like oh they this is how everybody goes except for Erica she has her own.
Erica Smith: process and you know that's why they essentially dedicated Allie to me because having the team having the team to figure all out what our process looked like because we didn't really have one was just asking way too much because when I wasn't there it kind of fell apart so because Siemens you know back in the day just really was the wild west and when I came on it was trying to wrangle the wild horses of the wild west and we did the best we could with what we had.
Erica Smith: So what we have is definitely better different because A, there is like an official process. So I joined Siemens in 2020.
Erica Smith: I was actually helping develop the platform that we were using just to find out at the.
Erica Smith: end of it all without the door because, you know, we're not moving forward with that. I would say this is probably a better process. Yes, search lessons learned. But I don't think that's the best way to do it. I don't know that there's any lessons that I've learned.
Erica Smith: I can see maybe some small steps that they think need to be wrinkled in, because there.
Erica Smith: are places that we still have, and there are some enhancements that we would like to see happen, but we also know that that's like way potentially down the road. Yeah, I mean, there's definitely some automation that could happen right now, but that's going to take a little bit of power of being to decide what that looks like, because right.
Erica Smith: now, I think one of the great examples that I have is that there's no, what we call delegation of authority, and I hate calling it anything shorter than that, because DOA and all of, I mean, something completely different than delegation of authority. Right now, if our engineers are ordering parts, it doesn't really get submitted to anybody for pricing. We have to reduce that down if we feel it needs to be approved.
Erica Smith: Because for me, anything I would say above $7,500, whether it's per part, I'm like, yeah, I'm going to go get $7,500 for that.
Erica Smith: Unless it is traditionally a more expensive part, that's what it feels like in my comfort zone.
Erica Smith: Coils can be that expensive, and that's actually where it gets reduced. But if you're talking about a board that's non-returnable to the vendor for restock, then yes, I'm taking down pricing approval.
Erica Smith: Whereas at Siemens, the engineer was given a $2,500 approval. The purchase price. ASM was given a $25,000.
Erica Smith: That is bad. The regional zone director was given $50,000, like a tier, a tertiary.
Sam Binder: They have a bunch of options, and then they upload the purchase order, and then we can watch the purchase order process, which should be quite, I believe it's the same across the board, so it might be really familiar to you already, but I don't know.
Jake Herwaldt: I need to choose a vendor once, you know, but then there's a, I need to upload and complete a PO.
Sam Binder: So choosing a vendor is done at the time that they upload the purchase order to them. So it's kind of like that, choosing a vendor, the trigger for that is to upload it. Cool.
Andrew Bailey: We actually put a software really struggling. Is it a PDF, or is it a PCO? Is it typically a PDF.
Sam Binder: Yes, it's a PDF. I don't want to limit it to a PDF. Okay. Because I have customers that want to upload Word docs. Yeah. Okay. Or pictures, like JPEGs.
Nathan Bedford: When you get pictures, that was curious.
Sam Binder: Lots of JPEGs. Yes. Yeah, absolutely. And it has to be drag and drop, because we told people it was drag and drop, and I learned that it's only drag and drop with certain documents, which is the...
Andrew Bailey: there's so many okay there is there's something to be so okay so now what we.
Jake Herwaldt: want to try and do is get through finishing the internal buyer it sounds like this is the beginning of creating a wreck yes okay going and then next is deciding on the vendor uploading the PO.
Steve Muniak: center of attention where we can improve her life is FSC sourcing and what are these other bubbles the returns like that on arrival I mean let's start to, think about what other bubbles and this is that.
Sam Binder: I would like to hear your purchase process and there are two there's one sourcing window which you guys care the most about to know that there isn't happens outside of circle for vendors who are not in source like oh yeah source like there's certain vendors by choice on the portal and both teams, opt-in by both ways the majority obviously in the in whatever we're calling it so I think you know the portal the platform okay so where do you.
Sam Binder: want me to start so you decided which vendor you're gonna buy from and then.
Erica Smith: what okay so I'm gonna I'm not gonna is this the sandbox no this is I'm going to kind of. click on anything um so this is the request that we got brandy is currently working on it so we look through take our vendor knowledge whether it be i will say block doesn't really have too much.
Erica Smith: on repairs things along they don't have like any contracts to go with these so it's truly who we're using and if you're on vacation how it's like does that mean it's a different decision based on whoever's very much so maybe very much so i may have a great relationship with. the andy on my team he doesn't like to recommend doesn't like their quality and we'll use that.
Erica Smith: So there is definitely personal preference if you put it to development and experience and relationships.
Vikki Dipple: There's so much that can go in. And it's because we don't have anything that's front and center saying actually their VO rate is this.
Nathan Bedford: We don't have accuracy bias. Some data informing that might be helpful, but I realize there's still going to be personal relationships, but data informing that might be more consistent. This is why I brought pizzas in every time.
Sam Binder: Yeah, you stole the pizzas. The whole team knew Steve from over here. They just threw me pizzas in on Thursday. Who is Steve? He ain't wrong.
Erica Smith: Is he really.
Erica Smith: He ain't wrong. Okay, this week.
Erica Smith: Yeah.
Erica Smith: Okay. So, you know, we'll look at everything that we've got and we've looked at all the requests. I will say that for responding in a time, we may have some that, sure, trust medical. in under everybody but if it takes you 45 minutes to put something out there goes your options there goes your opportunity because we don't have 45 our ordering is definitely much.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: quoting apart which that's a big difference between her team and my team for instance i could quote a customer based on all parts quoting the two thousand dollars but then my customer takes three hours to actually send a po or maybe not till the next day sometimes and in that time trust medical came in and they're only at nine hundred dollars well now i can go to trust medical and actually make more money off of them versus they're making more timely decisions, because we're actually still going to charge three the same with like three girls let's say i quoted three grand based on two thousand well now because your margin just got my margin just.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: got bigger so you actually want people to slow down well yeah sometimes we want to get more options i mean we some with some customers there is a time crunch because they're making faster decisions but when we know maybe we have a little bit more, find options, then we can quote based on someone that's higher and then end up either negotiating or buying from a different vendor that came in lower.
Steve Muniak: Let me throw the high level on top of this. She has time to wait for margin. She doesn't have time to wait for best price. If we can increase vendor response time and drive, like I said yesterday, if we drive our car materials down two or three percent, that's a million bucks very quickly. And margin's margin, so it's like you want. Yeah, margin's margin. So, helping her get to that best buy is the number one thing.
Erica Smith: And don't get me wrong, it's been a challenge to try to negotiate. Time is critical, and we don't have it. I have vendors that will be like, hey, what can we do to get this deal done? Hey, just give me your best price to begin with, and that's where we are at. Don't sit here and haggle with me. So, based on various different points of information, we'll go with who it is that we want.
Erica Smith: I look at a couple of different things when I make that decision. My colleagues may only look at two out of the three of the things that I look at. I look at, hey, is it worth making the use of the verbiage, depending on what part it is. Is it worth knowing that this client is going to probably run through a higher use machine to warranty on something. I take quite a few things for so long.
Erica Smith: So, I just kind of decide who we're going to use and just hit this add button. I'm sorry.
Andrew Bailey: Would that be a piece of information? you guys have access to or is that tribal knowledge that we try to share with the team? Would a requester, whether it's the hospital or the MSC, would they have that information on how often the machine is used? Is there like how many.
Erica Smith: miles you put on a car per day? Is it easy or is it difficult? I think the engineers, as long as they're established engineers, we just hired somebody and it's out there. But I think coming with experience systems that you have, you'll get the engineers that will sit there and tell you, hey, this is an ER seat. And they'll tell you that because they're telling you how quickly they need it. But that also tells you this is a high volume because it's being used in the ER multiple times a day, every day, 365.
Erica Smith: no downtime. So it comes with the tribal knowledge.
Andrew Bailey: The longer warranty in that case is a no-warranty. Exactly. But the longer warranty on a machine that's in a clinic that's used only in the five.
Erica Smith: occasionally. Two to three times a week, yes. And that's just something that I've been doing. I've been in procurement, 2013 and I've been in healthcare in mid-two, but it's been a place of defense of it. So I understand if we pay any part yesterday for an ERCT, I know that yes, critically.
Erica Smith: time, but if I can get a newer part, a new part in that shorter warranty or, something that happens the part is either it lasts from a customer or if there is a warranty situation we know it's under that the traditional so guys i'll drop in this for you this is a.
Steve Muniak: typical iso buyer that it's sort of very typical unless there's this unless we are trying medics we have contracts that we've awarded this mac this game this buying game of being knowledge, sammy had this incisive i don't think anybody can we call patty in here from sodexo now with. a this is a very typical negotiate because it's a time of week based on based on.
Andrew Bailey: Is there any way that you'd be able to organize or share the value of just bringing a more used part into a less used system, or into a longer one? Is there any way you'd be able to show, over time, that you doing this either saved your client's money, or saved you money, or is that pretty much, I mean, it's a good customer service.
Andrew Bailey: I mean, it seems like there's actually a lot of that happening, but you wouldn't be able to show anybody.
Sam Binder: I think you could, especially with the other customers and ISOs using the tools that have their information, you could pretty easily identify with data, high fail parts versus parts that don't typically fail. Those high fail parts you could indicate on the material record is a high fail part, which is not tribal knowledge anymore. You see it, and anyone can see, this is a part that is most likely to fail in that system. Every system has like five to ten parts. that are going to need to be replaced every year or six months and then there's parts that like almost never fail might never fail the entire lifespan of a system like uh so you get to learn.
Erica Smith: those on a ct with a brush block replaced sometimes once a year depending on the use of the system there's some systems that they get replaced it gets done on preventative maintenance where i, think like vicky was saying that the halo module are purchased or requested those those are even.
Erica Smith: something even more of detail because those are high fail they get replaced pretty frequently but, on top of that they're terrible shippers so there is a high chance if you need one, i usually will tell my engineer i recommend you getting two because the rate, high rate of that being DOA because you don't ship well because just the jostling something, into it's a 50 chance that will arrive DOA if you don't get one and as a vendor i don't want to give.
Sam Binder: a six month warranty on a part like that i don't give a one yeah if i'm negotiating with someone and i know that's a high failed part like yeah that's that's one of those things that we very.
Erica Smith: good yeah because they know it's gonna close to being in six months they're probably gonna because it's a high failed part and it's a highly that seems um out of scope a little bit for this.
Sam Binder: part of it but we did talk about the knowledge database is one of the requirements that we thought for the future 3.0 and this all would fit within the knowledge database of of living in the material part having this kind of information that's accessible to anyone that's paying to use the tool now has that will tell them kind of how to buy how to negotiate what.
Vikki Dipple: to expect to fail with all that stuff yeah if we had something you know rolling it out if we had. statistics or whatever we say even if you're putting it in there and you're requesting that part a little pop-up on the side most likely yeah you know that this part gets bought every, two minutes or part gets returned every or specific to a site like if it lived with a.
Vikki Dipple: dentist like a little box from ai that says oh yeah most likely returned oh yeah i'd love that.
Erica Smith: not even just ai but if you could if there was a way to see our eoa rate part for a vendor, part would be good to be able to pull that information to say hey this yeah it doesn't have to be like vendor specific it's just well yeah against all of our, what you're talking about there is I mean honestly this is what you're.
Andrew Bailey: talking about is when when the when the product work functions easily and well and the information that's asked for is relevant and timely that people typically bring it to completion whenever it's confusing unenforced or difficult or not a part of not a core part of the process because it has earned the right to be because email is the then nobody then then there's a lot of lost information it's rarely we often tell people like when we do a lot of AI.
Andrew Bailey: related projects but most companies would just stand for having a better UX with better that gathers relevant smart data and uses just some basic statistics it would show them everything that they need to know and AI is just so so unnecessary, for that then you very quickly get into something that becomes very useful but that's what you're talking about isn't isn't hard it's just well this is a relevant question asked at a relevant time with an interface that's extremely.
Andrew Bailey: easy to use and what used to be difficult is saying well there's like basically ten different questions based on what kind of part it is that would be relevant at this point well that used to be hard or it used to be it's really hard with the big building blocks it's quite a bit easier when you've got the intricate Legos right it was like oh okay well this part is of this type so these are the three questions that are most important and we ask it just the right time it's click all right move on right and if we didn't have it it's okay not to have it but it's really beneficial to have that.
Andrew Bailey: information here and you get a report of your FSC's saying oh how often do you ask and answer the questions and it's like oh you skip over it every time hey what's going on John you know this is a core part of our business let's do this together transparently thoughtfully, we've built something to make this really simple what's what's the disconnect here you know you didn't really do that but i just i get so you know sometimes i don't want to answer because i don't know the precise thing like oh i get it for you it's i want to you know what i mean this is how you build a product or a tool that really meets all of them all right i'll stop that because i.
Sam Binder: wanted jake's giving me the eyeball i can tell so we we made the really easy simple decision on how who to buy from yeah yeah and then you found super straightforward yeah easy to automate.
Erica Smith: it obviously so you you click the um so whichever you've selected in that part can you do that she can do anything until actually because this is already being worked at it's not hard so that's why i think i'm using this and you don't have to give up can you can you make a big break.
Sam Binder: Then you'd have to log in and quote to be able to.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: No, no, like, because she'd be able to just source it. But we can show this when we do, like, my process.
Sam Binder: Is it the same, though.
Jake Herwaldt: Yeah, how much overlap, I guess.
Erica Smith: At this point, it's probably the exact same thing. You add it to your cart. You add it to your cart, you process your cart, you create the PO, and then that's the shipping label.
Sam Binder: Can I ask a practical question, Mr. Boyk.
Nathan Bedford: If two people are working on the same order right now, what does that look like? What does that have to do with it.
Sam Binder: They won't. It's assigned to a person.
Nathan Bedford: Meaning they can't or they just don't.
Sam Binder: No, they don't. They don't.
Nathan Bedford: But they could. I mean, like, if they could, which they probably never do, but somebody doesn't want to come out, how do you want that? Like, I'm thinking how we build it. Should we have it be locked while somebody's working on it? No. You can just represent it like the process.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: Right, so, like, for my team, so my team is commission-based. So let's say I'm on vacation. But I quoted a customer apart if I'm on vacation someone else on my team needs to be able to process that order However, I stay the owner of that whole requisition So I'm commissioned on that sale, but someone on my team actually processes the order to get it actually shipped out.
Sam Binder: Okay, but on all the records it does say the owner name. So it's the internal policies fixes. Yes.
Nathan Bedford: Yeah, like tonight I'm checking out my computer parts. My wife sneaks in a hair tie. Yeah, Just not gonna happen if you guys talk about it.
Erica Smith: Like this, that's the easier way to handle it. Yeah, you can see right here over here on this side You can see that the engineer chattered us saying hey everything looks good, Brandi told us because you were paying I'm worse, Oh, that's it. The rest of us are like, okay We're moving to tell you through that board. This is how and so you guys got to look there And so I'll show you, We will get.
Erica Smith: So this was the email that we got in response to Chatter. Hey, so that way we know it's been taken care of.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: So instead of Chatter, like when you assign it to yourself, it's that once someone assigns it to themselves, that then the notification goes out saying like Brandy's working on this instead of having her manually add it.
Sam Binder: There's so many things we could do to automate it, but it's all out of scope.
Nathan Bedford: You've seen what I'm seeing.
Sam Binder: Chattering is a lot.
Nathan Bedford: We'll build it like this, but we're thinking about how we can do it a little better.
Erica Smith: We don't assign things for ourselves. We don't put brackets in the middle. So it doesn't say what it wants. So we don't have a queue, so we don't assign anything. Have you seen the checkout process already.
Sam Binder: Did you guys do that yesterday? Okay.
Nathan Bedford: Well, I remember we actually started going near the end. Yeah, we should spend some time on that.
Sam Binder: So someone's going to need to log in if she can't do the checkout. I don't know if that's something you want to do real quick. I can't. Add to cart, upload to a page. I would do it in the sandbox.
Jake Herwaldt: Yes, and you're going to be doing it as an external buyer. Is that where you're doing it.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: Yeah, an internal buyer.
Jordan Clark: While they're making that switch, I just want to call out, you know, something that Erica had mentioned as it impacts the return side, because that may get brought up, the return space. So Erica's making all these very intentional decisions around warranty and cost and what's fast to send in. And then on the back end of that, we have the responsibility at the FSC level to get that exchange part back to us or send that warranty claim part back to us. And so oftentimes we have a scenario where Erica's being really intentional to get a part maybe at a higher cost for more value from one perspective.
Jordan Clark: But if we don't complete that exchange or if we don't close the gap on that, there's a cost prohibitive factor to this. And so our returns process from engineers from the field is so clunky that we're struggling with this to the extent that sometimes what looks like an incentive on the front end turns out to be a cost prohibitive factor.
Steve Muniak: into dollars okay Jordan how how are how do FSC's manage very haphazardly what.
Jordan Clark: what tools are do they have access I know there's a member on the returns team that is is strategically working with some engineers in the field kind of on a trial basis right now outside of that I know. it's more on the service side but I know there's a recording that goes out regularly from the return steam like the other report on the status I mean.
Erica Smith: it's there's there's a lot of that bucket the engineers know that they have something to purchase on it here's your shipping label to send it back. And then there's reporting that we get, hey, what's still up? We try, and I think that we're very recently, that we try to reach out to them.
Erica Smith: Hey, you've got this. If we need to get it. Our dwindling because we're getting trying. To turn this into, again, the return.
Steve Muniak: If we have the ability to decrease core return exposure, that's a great value. You could have a million dollars in cores out there.
Sam Binder: For sure. Easily.
Erica Smith: That's a small number, I'm pretty sure.
Sam Binder: I mean, there are multiple tubes, but we don't even know where they're at.
Steve Muniak: and then give it time it really comes down to the avoid guys it comes down to the responsibility of the guy who took that out of the machine to take care of it and get it back.
Jordan Clark: sorry the difficulty with that right now i feel like we owe the engineer a better system process for this and then there's also a tension of of like what's the next most burning thing yeah so if erica and team are sending them okay we fix this ct and now we gotta hop across town and go to this one that exchange very quickly becomes like back burner like this is not on my.
Sam Binder: radar especially if it's freight because the hospitals need it to go to a spot in the hospital and then it's literally lost in a hospital you know and then nobody really knows what box it's in people trying to track down a freight shipment it's do they even is it as simple as like do they.
Jake Herwaldt: even have any paperwork that goes with that item so could it literally just be an item sitting.
Sam Binder: there's a yes that could happen where there's no paperwork there's nothing identifiable ideally.
Erica Smith: there they always have people, work.
Jake Herwaldt: Right, right.
Erica Smith: Yeah, yeah, yeah. With vendors? For engineers to have. Pre-printed, return labels. They literally just slap that pre-printed label on there.
Erica Smith: Yeah, that would be really good. In the box. Write the RMA on the label. That's how we did it at Aramark. Was it a lot more successful.
Jordan Clark: It's not always that we don't actually get a part, it's the timeline. So there's a terms and conditions element to it. When you're owing a part to a vendor, you've got a timeline to work within. And so a lot of times, we're not acting on it in a timely manner that allows us to get out of that additional bill and pay more for that part just because we didn't need the time required.
Sam Binder: So when you say exchange price and outright price, exchange price is what you pay unless you don't get the exchange back in that timeline. Then the outright price is what you're billed.
Nathan Bedford: I have one more question. I deal with this with batteries myself. I haven't been using them in a garage for a long time. It feels like eventually there's a real ROI that's easy to calculate for a specialized business. Because there's real money to be left on there.
Sam Binder: A ton of money. And this is also, when we talked 3.0 build out of this premium version, we're building it for the engineers to purchase. participate, this is to be part of it. And it ties into the Returns and Exchanges module. But this is for the engineers. An engineer, even in Block FSC, should be able to open an app or whatever on their phone and see, here's all the parts I owe to Block. Here's when they're due. And here's, in a perfect world, the repercussions of when I don't do that. They can do it. It's just that. I've not made it easy enough, though. They can do that if they log in and soar and filter and ask questions and respond to chatter.
Sam Binder: But if we made it so that there's a dashboard that's what they see, and then we hold them accountable, which we're also not doing.
Jake Herwaldt: Yeah, that's a fancy piece. But even, Steve and I were just talking about it. Imagine it's like Amazon takes a picture of the package at your door. It needs to be that simple, right? Which is outside the scope of what we did define. But I think it's something. I would like us to walk through that. I heard you mention Returns. I want to walk through that. I genuinely want to finish this, but we keep squirreling. I want to finish it. And then I want to jump to Returns and RMAs,
Jake Herwaldt: because of the . To me, that's huge, and something we can do in parallel.
Sam Binder: We should offer financial bonuses to the engineers. Okay. We're going to call the exchanges in a quarter. I mean, that's like sales money.
Erica Smith: Yeah, absolutely. Okay.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: So, quoted a customer based off of a source price. So, the customer sent their purchase order to me, or in Erica's case, they just found what they needed. So, we're adding vendor that we chose option to our cart. So, on the first page, it's asking me if I'm buying it on exchange or on override, and that's driven by the customer. For you guys, it's usually exchange.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: So, same with me. There's some that I just kind of... So, now it's added to my cart, and if there were additional parts on the rack, we would do whatever, but... So then we're going to the part and it auto-fills some things but for the most part we have to fill out a lot of this. So customers PO number.
Jake Herwaldt: Because that's unique to them.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: That's unique to them for invoicing.
Sam Binder: This is essentially the sales order in a sales process that he covers.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: How they want it shipped.
Jake Herwaldt: Which could have gotten pulled. It could, yeah. It's all there. It's all on the PO. It's all on the PO. All of this is on the PO. The PO number is on there.
Sam Binder: And these are required fields. But you wouldn't know it. Unless you don't. Because there's no indicator that it's required. Well it tells you it's required. When you save it. It tells you all of the required fields and you have to guess which one you didn't fill out.
Erica Smith: So if you were to save it from here, it doesn't tell you hey you need to fill it out. You have to go three steps forward to realize you missed three steps forward.
Sam Binder: On a different record back there. It's awful. Just don't make mistakes.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: Pretty much. So then we're filling out attention to, phone number. If it's shipping on a customer's account, then we would put in an ex-account as well.
Jake Herwaldt: Blindship means, like, don't say it's coming. Correct. There's something. There's identifiers on it somewhere.
Sam Binder: Is that because we're really bad at blindship.
Jake Herwaldt: This is Salesforce. This is not sourcing.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: Correct. This is all Salesforce. So, and then, or it's shipping to, so I'm saving, all of that. So she's still in her cart. So I'm still in my cart. Now I'm checking out.
Jake Herwaldt: That was just prepping the check-in.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: So with all of my information, that's kind of like, are you sure? Like, is everything good? It's your last chance. But that's your purchase order. She just now created her purchase order. I just created my purchase order.
Sam Binder: When you submit that last record, it creates the purchase order. So the information for the purchase order lives in that last record. Go down here to this tab.
Jake Herwaldt: This is saying Block is selling this to someone. Block is getting it from them.
Erica Smith: Because this is the org for Keo now.
Jake Herwaldt: So you're buying this from? From Virtus. Oh, you're buying it from Virtus.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: So now this is the video.
Jake Herwaldt: So the dropship is going straight from them to the customer.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: So now we're in the PO module. And so this is where I would make my shipping label. Because we send, 99% of the time, we're sending shipping labels to our vendors to use. So we're able to trash the part. So shipping from Block Imaging, shipping to this. hospital in Texas that I chose. This is where you would put like the weights and the DIM.
Sam Binder: Of the box that you don't know? If it's small personal, we guess. We just put something standard. It only really matters when it's a freight. Anything under 150 pounds, it doesn't technically really matter. We don't pay any free weight fees or anything at FedEx? Yeah. They'll just end up billing us the true amount. So we don't care.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: So then, this is kind of a pain in the butt. Even though I chose, FedEx priority on my cart, it always defaults to ground here. So we always have to manually make sure and change, yet again, what shipping priority.
Jake Herwaldt: that we want. Now, if you didn't have this stuck in your brain because you're working, what are you going back to? Because you're stuck on this screen, right? I would have to go back to, I have another tab. You literally keep tabs open so that you can jump back and forth.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: Yes, if I need to. So I can go back to my cart and look at all the work. So, changing it back to priority overnight, it's going to ship on the customer's account. party billing part here, getting save, generate, label, and then that's what creates, okay.
Nathan Bedford: That'd be nice to see when you're typing it in.
Sam Binder: Oh my gosh.
Nathan Bedford: Might as well do it during that. But one thing Steve is pointing out is this is the internal flow, which we're not going to be right.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: Right, but this is how we have to get to, this is how we get to what the vendors do.
Nathan Bedford: No, it's great. It's making me think like, man, I don't want to make this part better. We can't with the first version, at least, with whatever. But like, how different categorically is it then? Is it very, is the checkout process steps similar, internal versus external? Very similar. How about that.
Sam Binder: External, like sources. Do you mean SWP.
Vikki Dipple: So a buyer is not going to go through this cart process like this. They just. All they're going to fill out is a cart page, like. fill out my PO number, upload my PO, submit my PO, and they're done.
Sam Binder: This is a great way for you to see our API that we have with FedEx because Block Imaging built that for ourselves. We want that same API with FedEx in for our customers and engineers because then the engineers can do it.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: So then labels created, the tracking number right there. So then the next thing would be to PDF the, huh? What did you say? Will you pretend to save it all? I know, I'm not going to. Okay. Yeah, but like, so here's the PO, we would PDF this.
Jake Herwaldt: And now you're going to attach all of these to an email.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: No. So now we're in SW fulfillment. So I've created my label. I have a PDF of my purchase order that we save in job folders.
Sam Binder: Just to also, this is the portal now. So this is all the portal. Yes. This is the same view vendors have, the same view customers have. Their version of this view is here, but this is the portal.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: Okay. So I would hit.
Sam Binder: So to take a step back here, this view, if I were Virtus, logged into sourcing window, sitting there on my order page, I could see this information pop up because it's a record that she created and it's linked. It's the same thing. But I'm not notified until the buyer, in this case, they know about Ali, actually presses that button. That's the notification. We don't want vendors to see that it's there until we press that because there are times.
Sam Binder: we made a mistake on the PO and we actually delete it out and then upload a new PO. So at first they were just, it was live. Like everything that we did was live. still live and then realize which could cause it could cause confusion and so now the trigger is very attentional in that point so like this is what Brutus when they log in and they have a pending fulfillment so that and then they have the email with the link that takes them directly to the PO documents.
Jake Herwaldt: which I can show you later but can you go back to that here so this is the experience that someone can you can you scroll back up to the top you checked what did it all did you have to do just that checking is submitting and every vendor has that or just block just block it so this is that's like an external vendor do they have the same check box they don't an external vendor.
Sam Binder: does not an external vendor though had this confirmation yeah you can put there if you want so you can see what they wait for so they don't have that check box identical without this and then there's some things that we display, At least then, like, down below.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: And, like, if I was...
Sam Binder: Yeah.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: Which, this is that one that we parking lotted yesterday, Steve, about, like, two different chatters. Because if I would have, like, chattered Virtus EMA on the SRC originally, so let's say I would have asked here, like, for pictures or whatever, so we have this whole chat pre-me.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: buying it, but then in the order, that doesn't pull over, and now it's a whole other chat.
Jake Herwaldt: So this is, like, is this, like, a post-purchase chat? Correct. Basically.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: It would be nice if it goes through the history. So, yeah. So then the vendor would click confirm order, which then we would get a confirmation, like.
Jake Herwaldt: Which confirmed means I've shipped it or I've seen you.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: Confirmed means I've got it.
Jake Herwaldt: Okay.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: And I'm going to process it. I see you. I'm processing it. We do not know that it was actually shipped until they fill out, which again, kind of what Sam was saying yesterday, redundant for them to put in, that the vendor has to put in a tracking number when we've given them a label.
Sam Binder: Yep.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: So it would be nice if that kind of just auto.
Sam Binder: And we have it in Salesforce in a few because we created the label.
Jake Herwaldt: Well, and you have it in the PDF.
Sam Binder: And we have it in the PDF. Right.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: But it, but then they need the serial number of the part that shipped because that's the individual part.
Sam Binder: I'm responsible for selling. Yeah. I'm responsible for selling the part. Right. So I want to say it's shipped. I know it's shipping, but my inventory. Okay. team is the one that pulls the part, got the serial number, and then there's a return team that's creating the RMA. But I have to have all three of these fields to be able to say I shipped the part. It could take a whole day for people to gather that information.
Jake Herwaldt: internally. I could have already shipped it. I could have shipped it. Before this is actually.
Sam Binder: created. But I can't communicate because of blocks too. I can't communicate to my customer and ship unless I have all this information and sometimes that's hard. We made it though so you can fill out one or two of the fields and save it without it notifying the customer. So the email that goes out that says your parts have shipped, it doesn't actually send it until all three fields are satisfied, but the vendor for their own reference can save.
Jake Herwaldt: it. So in this tracking number, when they put that in, and let's just say you put in all of this stuff right now, when you update shipping, what gets sent to the customer that.
Sam Binder: this is for? Your parts have shipped. Do they get the tracking number? It's awesome. It's.
Vikki Dipple: If you fill those out, you can go to the PEO record and see the email.
Sam Binder: It is an awesome way to fight heart failure. It even has a link to heart. If you click the link with the tracking number, it takes you to Google. It's like it goes to FedEx where you can see the updates. But Google searches the heart number, which is tracking.
Vikki Dipple: Don't hate on us too hard.
Erica Smith: No, no. I know, I said it's like great news and all that. Don't look too hard. I was curious if this triggers, like, now are you going auto.
Sam Binder: It's really hot. We would love for test stores to be able to opt into that. And honestly, it's the vendor. I'm sorry, it's the FSE on the site that needs to know that information, not the buyer.
Jake Herwaldt: Oh, right, you almost want to forward that to someone.
Sam Binder: We would love to have them opt in via text. I want a text message that that heart is delivering in 30 minutes. Like, that would be awesome.
Jake Herwaldt: So this is the awesome thing.
Sam Binder: Yeah. Okay. So this is kind of cool, too, because we have different digital experiences, right? So because Block Imaging sold this part to a non-SDBP customer, the logo is Block Imaging. But if the vendor was a Direct Connect to a Sourcing Window customer, it says Sourcing Window. And if it's a Customer Communication, it says Sourcing Window Pro.
Sam Binder: So it looks kind of sleek and cool and you know who you're communicating with.
Andrew Bailey: Did you see your coffee on your desk? He happened to catch me going out to my car to grab my phone, and I didn't have my keys. And he's like, give me your keys, I'll go get them for you.
Jake Herwaldt: Cool. So now you're done. He's a good guy. Now, can we walk through that same flow of a fully in-sourcing window? Because that's what this is, right.
Erica Smith: Yes.
Jake Herwaldt: That would be cool. which is a little different the checkout experience is similar yeah it's just a lot easier because.
Sam Binder: they're not we're creating our purchase order yeah and our sales order while we do that they already get that they're just adding a couple things and go over I'm asking like for me like.
Nathan Bedford: from a product perspective having the same thing in two systems is a maintenance night, fix something in one system you get a rebuild another like obviously long-term unifying that flow even if it means we're embedding something inside Salesforce is like I think we'd want to go that's what I'm trying to figure out like you would just hide and show certain parts you'd obviously make the changes they fit that customer need best but it's like mostly the same yes you.
Jake Herwaldt: almost hate the idea of this one being three features ahead of sales right that's what would where you guys truly should have the message and that together it's back to that dynamic of being.
Steve Muniak: So, we're moving now to external buyer.
Jake Herwaldt: Yeah, I want to see this flow from an external buyer standpoint and the blanks at the end for us to come back to.
Sam Binder: Yeah, go ahead and log in.
Steve Muniak: We've got Erica for 40 minutes, 34 more minutes.
Sam Binder: Oh, actually, then should we go into the returns bit.
Steve Muniak: Yes. Oh, would that be helpful.
Sam Binder: Yeah. Okay, great. Yeah. So, now you and Jordan are going to run the show.
Erica Smith: Yeah, sure. So, when you return. I feel like he probably more will run the show, but I won't. We want screens again, so you want again. Do you want to do that? I don't know. Do you want screens? They prefer screens. I don't know that I really want to do screens.
Jordan Clark: I have one. We have a sourcing window facing the inside. So. even get like we generally are only no because we're communicating to our internet what is the.
Vikki Dipple: amazing thing that's the only dma is the chat like messaging up i'm coming back to them.
Jordan Clark: so post sales if we need an rma number or anything to get a return, physically back to a vendor i'll hop into it or someone on my team will jump in and have have communication with the vendor most frequently that happens when the original rma provider is for an exchange but then we got like a restock or a quality return which i think i mentioned yesterday like differentiating our main numbers is kind of a pain point right now i gotta back.
Andrew Bailey: myself up um i'm gonna fast forward through a couple things we've got this qvc item there's a visit, There's a part, the part, an RMA attached to it if it is something that can be exchanged.
Erica Smith: Purchased on exchange, we will automatically exchange it.
Andrew Bailey: What does RMA stand for.
Erica Smith: Return material.
Andrew Bailey: Oh, okay, so that's why it's not the same as a part ID, or it's not the same. This is a, they pre-authorize this. Yes. So almost like another PO that automatically exists related to this thing, or another kind of like transactional number.
Erica Smith: It ties it to the order.
Andrew Bailey: Yeah, it ties it to the order. Because everybody in the industry decides that this is the useful way to do it. Yeah, a dead-on arrival becomes a new RMA. Hold on, I'm getting ready. Stop it. You're rushing me. This is, the other, can you run into the real reason why I do the most talking? Because it takes me the longest to understand things. Like by the time Andy gets it, Nate and Jacob have already built it. That's the whole reason why I do the most talking. Okay, so. Do you want me to run through it real quick? All right. I wish I thought I could comprehend that. I wish I thought I could. I think we can comprehend that.
Andrew Bailey: Do you want to just try it? Yeah, let's try it. I think you can run through it. Well, I tried that, and then I all of a sudden was like, ooh.
Jordan Clark: We were in like one little subsection of it. We didn't go high, high.
Erica Smith: Okay, so here's how it goes. The order of that order automatically has a particular number that is generated by the, words in exchange. They can't base it on serial number, but they're obviously being parked back. It's the exchange. Our engineers, hey, I either don't need this, I'm claiming warranty on this DOA, that then to go back to the vendor to say, hey, we need to, we need to change our return.
Erica Smith: Because we are not sending you an exchange anymore. We're sending you back the same part for whatever reason. Some of them specific warranty, DOA. RMAs, there's different digit in front of where it's just a whole new, that's very vendor specific, but it's still, you're getting a new.
Jordan Clark: And do you usually have that communication on the chatter in the SRC record or the PO record.
Erica Smith: Nope, it's on the PO record. So that's on this window to show the chatter. Yeah.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: So like for this one, I brought one up, I bought this card on exchange, it ended up failing under warrant. So we have this giant conversation with the vendor.
Andrew Bailey: This was a couple, immediately or weeks later.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: It could be. This was like a month later.
Andrew Bailey: Yeah, because I would consider a DOA to be, I immediately didn't feel it.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: So there's DOA, but then there's also failed under warranty. So which means like a.
Andrew Bailey: So in that warranty, you went back to this purchase order.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: Yes, the original purchase order.
Andrew Bailey: To navigate this.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: To chatter and pay from direct. Okay.
Andrew Bailey: You can see why that would be confusing.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: To say, this failed under warranty, so they gave me a 90-day warranty. It failed within those 90 days. So we have a lot of, because they, and then they give me a new RMA number to use to send back a failed part.
Andrew Bailey: Because then they're going to give you, they're going to send immediately a new part out.
Sam Binder: If I, yeah. Just issue a new PO, which is a warranty process, but we haven't looked at that yet. Yeah.
Steve Muniak: And guys, throughout the entire RMA process, all of the events are time-bound. So if an exchange is due back, that exchange is due back within 15 days, if it's not received, then there is no credit nearby. Then you're going to get canceled.
Vikki Dipple: But it's also very vendor-specific. There's industry generals, but it is vendor-specific and not physical.
Nathan Bedford: You can negotiate. So it's not transparent.
Vikki Dipple: It's not transparent when you make a PO or in communication, as it can vary.
Andrew Bailey: Okay, should a vendor when you guys have a vendor sign up to use Should they say what is your policy.
Nathan Bedford: You have to search through this chatter to find that our mayor's, okay.
Steve Muniak: And then we do it that other part about that is we do have a vendor record and should live with that information.
Andrew Bailey: No, no, I wanted it. Well, this seems very straightforward as far as I get the confusion, but the confusion is is more the Trying to it's all in the same space and a generalized number for three different situations there We were just whatever futures they would look at talking. How do we name things three specific ways? I don't care that you guys that it's all the same number yeah and that it's a.
Andrew Bailey: that there's a generalized idea about this number like the software has doesn't ever get mad about saying well this is an exchange this is a warrant, whatever it's just guiding you through the process required even if the process is the same having visual cues to say oh I'm working through an exchange I'm working through a debt on arrival I'm working through this it's, actually very good it doesn't mind being the same and this is all internally.
Jordan Clark: documented within Salesforce as well because as we're going through that process and lining it up and getting things in place when that part is physically received it's going through a process on what we call return item or written return item number and they are documented with that specific type and, warranty restock do a whatever it may be yeah is the confusing part for the part.
Andrew Bailey: that makes it, because there are a lot of people who can drop the ball you can accidentally use the wrong number the field service employee can not send it back the hospital that maybe have the package could not get it to the right thing.
Jordan Clark: there's a lot of people the timely factor that is the biggest issue the other thing to keep in mind as well as when you're looking at internal buyers and external buyers there's a different risk association to it so when Ali's team sells this part and buys it from a vendor we're gonna get a bad bill for that part not being returned to the vendor we can turn around and add bill that customer on the service side that customer is paying at the contract level they're paying for the service of the equipment they're not paying for the.
Jordan Clark: part so when we don't get that part back from a service contract an internal buyer perspective it just doubles our cost of servicing that piece of equipment.
Steve Muniak: or I'll throw another part into that if it's an in-part stock, We can't bring back your data.
Jordan Clark: Correct.
Andrew Bailey: This is that one at the very beginning about the difference, what struggles come from using big LEGO blocks and what struggles come from integrating a tool. We're talking about, right now, block tooling. These are things that are supposed to make block more efficient. But they're either underdeveloped, or block systems have gotten bigger, or intuition got more complex. This one feels more like that's not a tool that's part of sourcing. Because the returns and exchanges are, but the complexity, like certain things that you just said,
Andrew Bailey: of, well, block gets this, and then it has that tool. That's a tooling concept.
Jordan Clark: It's a tension of priority, I think, across departments. Where there are some minor things, like RMA formatting and communication between vendors and how it's documented, I think that's an easier thing to say. Oh, we can pinpoint this. And the other thing is, it's much more from a perspective of, how are we prioritizing? processes within the timeline for the multiple people that are involved in the decisions, but once a part gets.
Andrew Bailey: delivered and installed, Basically within one day. I'm just going to use it a very short period of time You know whether it's dead on a run because and then essentially if it's longer than 24 hour that there's some amount of time It's not going to be but, Right, but in the beginning of the first thing is if there could be something if a number was generated right away Then it's because they're going to send back the exchange So there's an exchange, Concept and then the second concept would be the only thing that would maybe overwrite an exchange would be a dead-on-arrival.
Andrew Bailey: Then I would say okay well that exchange is no longer valid at this point because but we're going to need to complete the DOA and then decide whether or not that exchange is still valid because that exchange might be cancelled because we're not going to go with that same vendor and so We need to do something else or that exchange could still be valid We're just going to send another part and then do, the exchange on that one, is that still true? Okay. The transactions are a little bit more separated.
Jordan Clark: but yes.
Andrew Bailey: Sure. But once the parts are installed, then is it the field service engineer who's responsible for making sure that exchange happens, or is it somebody else.
Vikki Dipple: It depends on the service of the internal engineer.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: Oh, okay, external engineer. So like, it could be. We also deal with customers who, there's some people that just ship it to us directly. However, there are some companies like PartSource that it has to go to their internal returns warehouse first to process, then it comes back to us.
Andrew Bailey: Oh, you guys have to be accommodating.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: We are to certain customers.
Andrew Bailey: At the end of the day, there's gonna be some incomplete, this is part of that smart homepage, that smart queue. There's something that has a time span and it hasn't been addressed, and it's more than five days old. We're like, wait a second, is that normal? Is that common? that becomes a red flag in the system that's like hey this is five days is a long time for this not to be complete did somebody go on vacation um did somebody not do their job but let's pretend now everything got installed this came back i'm not saying i'm not saying we've we've uncovered a.
Andrew Bailey: complexity there i'm just saying we know we're aware of that complexity so now it actually gets installed um if it happens within a certain number of days really the record which should only be allowed to create a warranty if it's within a number of days that should be on or could be on.
Sam Binder: the part or could be sold with a 90-day warranty they shouldn't be allowed to do a warranty thing.
Andrew Bailey: right that but that button could exist on there because it says oh this part has a 90-day.
Jake Herwaldt: warranty the date installed is that currently happening in certain oh it is a requirement, yeah no.
Sam Binder: We have nothing to order.
Jake Herwaldt: Yeah, like there's no button right now for them to click.
Sam Binder: But that is a requirement to add.
Jake Herwaldt: Right, this is why, or I guess, are you just, yeah.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: There's like no returns type module. That's correct.
Sam Binder: The ability to process a warranty order, though, is like the first thing they do before we even build out the returns. So right now, if I'm a SWP customer, and I purchased a part from, doesn't matter, let's say Block Imaging, and that part failed, I don't have any way of communicating to Block, oh, can you send another one? Because Block needs to send a PO. I can't send a PO because all of my records are closed. You have to do it outside of the machine.
Vikki Dipple: I have to do it outside of the machine. Or there's a brand new requisition. And then our team doesn't know. All those vendors, do you know I'm going to buy this from Block because it's a warranty order.
Andrew Bailey: Because you're going to chat, you're going to say, hey, Block, this is not actually a new request.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: It's actually rare that they chatter us in the tool saying that it failed on your warranty.
Sam Binder: They're not supposed to. They're either calling. There's a. Yep. We have instructed that they do it outside the tool because we cannot accommodate that. So that is a baseline requirement for the first rebuild. To be able to say that they need to return something.
Andrew Bailey: But that would be interesting. Like if a customer's history, I bought this and these are the ones that are still under warranty. Yes. It would be a button that says...
Jake Herwaldt: But I mean, there's so many assumptions in that. Like in doing that, it's like, are you on every single part outlining what the warranty is for them? Yeah.
Sam Binder: So you're adding a step. But it's already in there. The tool already has that information. So it would really be just displaying the information they already agreed to.
Jake Herwaldt: The external buyer and vendor put in that info.
Sam Binder: Yes. It's a required field. Okay. Yep. On the SRC record, it is a required field. Okay. So it wouldn't be getting new data. It would just be displaying it in a different...
Andrew Bailey: Yeah. That's there. And allowing. And then, so warranty is they click, they say, hey, warranty, you guys would need to have a conversation with them. Yeah. i'm sure that there are certain things that like warranty but that's probably a small percentage probably most warranties are honored the true they when we receive them they go through a validation.
Jordan Clark: process and and we determine if it's a valid or invalid claim that's what after you actually see the part that has impact on credit outcome and all of that yeah that's actually because they.
Vikki Dipple: can say it's claimed like a lot of times they'll claim it was doa but we get it back they find out the parts actually working they just didn't know how to install it correctly it's about 30.
Jordan Clark: percent about 30 percent of doa claims are actually invalid they're good parts i think we're hovering around 35 percent like that generally what we end up doing is providing testing report disproving that claim and then if it's an external buyer we're sending them a restock credit memo and treating it as though they just sent it back and not needed so they'll pay.
Steve Muniak: the tricky vendors the tricky customers know how to play that and they'll call a warranty, They'll get a free restock as opposed to restock and basically restock fees for them.
Andrew Bailey: Yeah, so there is a but there is a, warranty process end to end minimum a week maximum three weeks.
Sam Binder: Maximum whatever the warranty length is. No, no, no.
Andrew Bailey: I'm saying like once the warranty started because they got to send it you guys got to confirm it minimum.
Jordan Clark: We give ourselves a 30-day window for validation.
Andrew Bailey: Okay, so so but could be as short as a couple weeks could be as long as we say average probably 15 to 30 days Okay, but from the time that they actually first triggered it maybe an extra week out of that So it's that entity that process is going to be you know, whatever whatever tool is visualizing this It's like here's where we're at the process. It's its own workflow. It's its own set of informations and knobs and so.
Andrew Bailey: But the whole RMA issue is just simply that there's a, just in the same way that a tracking number is a commitment from whatever sending service is like, hey, here's the number you used to do this, this number is we requesting a number for you so that if we send something back to you, and sometimes it's associated with the core exchange, sometimes it's a warranty, sometimes it's a dead on arrival, because they're all going to be different things for their system.
Jordan Clark: Yeah, there would be five, actually. So there'd be DOA, warranty, restock, exchange, acceptable, and unacceptable is more of a cosmetic or a call out. So if they got dropped by FedEx or was poorly packed and had some cosmetic damage to it. claim would be made which is treated much in the same lens of quality claim it's normally a call for us to dive into our process of packing and all those different things and is all of that.
Andrew Bailey: is the complexity because this a lot of this is handled in this original purchase order that was all around the purchase or is that the only thing that would happen at least prefer it here because.
Vikki Dipple: it's stamped with that po would have a record i can't delete anything i can't miss mail with that i hope you still oh you said i could do it here if i just did this it's all stamped here and it's, visible for the vendor or the buyer yeah but when you so it's like a record remember we made that.
Andrew Bailey: life of a part and part of the reason we did that is because the part was the start is the the entity that is generating value generating money and so when you think about this like this is, A PO is a relationship, but it is a, there's so many things that happen with it, it is only one piece of the relationship, it is an ideal relationship, right, but then a part can be a better teller of the stages of a relationship, right, the part, that purchase order is the initial agreement, but there are other aspects of the relationship that this part will have more access to, it's going to tell a bigger story, and so once we focus in on the part, we just let you know,
Andrew Bailey: here, it was the original service order, it was the purchase order that came with it, you know, it's going to know, it'll tell the whole story, like, hey, here's how I came in and blocked, and they want to know, well, I want to know how we got this part, because I want to know, oh, we got this from this machine, and we priced this out, look how much money we made on this machine, and look at, you know, what we got to do there, there's some other things there, but that's probably just us shifting when we, built the infrastructure correctly we just kind of shift the lens the, software to say we'll tell the story of the part now and while we focus in on.
Andrew Bailey: this warranty portfolio or focus in on this debt on the right.
Sam Binder: It does live on the serial number record doesn't it? In theory every touch is documented from harvest to testing.
Jordan Clark: Did you say the serial number record? The inventory record.
Aly Boggs-Smitley: Do you have like inventory details? You can look at your inventory movements.
Jordan Clark: It's generally you don't like actually see like a linear relationship where you could just read through the list. You'd actually have to go into the inventory movements and see how it moved in and out of stage and status which our team and it ends up getting to like very disconnected so inventory movements might be tied to technical orders and so you're really jumping into the spider web.
Sam Binder: I remember doing a site visit to all parts and I watched them scan the QR code on the part and it brought up their I don't know what the name they called it their serial number record or whatever and it had, Every time any human hand touched that part was documented with a time and date stamp, the name of the person that touched it, what was done, whether it was repaired, the customer it shipped out to, and it had, like, all the associated records, and it was, like, so happy. It made me so happy. Yeah.
Jordan Clark: Inventory movements is kind of a...
Sam Binder: But I feel like that's more of what he's talking about, where it's, like, the complete story of Block's relationship with that part.
Vikki Dipple: So those are beautiful, tiny little Lego keys.
Sam Binder: That's true.
Andrew Bailey: Yeah. And then this is... So this RMA can represent the exchange, the DOA, the warranty. You said two others. There's a restock and unacceptable. And all of those... The reason why I'm just focusing on this is because... Unacceptable. That's why I did it. Unacceptable. Is that... I can see why this would be confusing.
Andrew Bailey: Labels matter on a piece of software. Like, what are you doing? It will be interesting to have that conversation and to say, well, like, does the header on the thing say, we're doing an exchange, what's the RMA, or is it better to say exchange RMA, DOA RMA, right? Because we want to use, and we don't have to make that decision right now, I'm mostly just pointing out.
Vikki Dipple: They wouldn't all have their own unique, like an exchange would have its own unique, but then any other type of a return, it's almost like a different drop for a return. Because a return is going to have the exact same serial number of the part that was shipped out, but the reason for that return may be one of those.
Andrew Bailey: Because this is the serial number it doesn't, they don't know about, this is the serial number they do know about.
Jordan Clark: That's the first thing we check, is the serial number, the part to confirm, was this actually an exchange? The plain return is, hey, we're expecting an exchange, this is a plain $40,000 transaction. The unflamed return is like, hey, something happened to cause this. Okay. Deviate from the original course. Okay.
Jake Herwaldt: we've got the 10 minutes you know they call that like they know what's coming and this is where we're glossing over a lot of like how like what does sales for your somebody because that's the thing it's like yes the data is the system some of these requirements that my brain goes so okay.
Jake Herwaldt: what does sales force mean actually then trigger those your internal process so that it is as, it's like because currently it's just email and then you guys go into sales so are you dreaming a dream state right now well I'm more wondering like how practically for example if I am a vendor.
Sam Binder: no if I'm a customer network and I want to claim that one of the parts I bought from our sources do, I log into their tool, and I could log into their PartSource Pro. She's talking about a whole different customer that has nothing to do with this. Well, we talked about PartSource being the ones that you guys should watch and look at and see how they do, because they are our competitors. They have something like this. I don't want to copy them, but what they did is, I would file, they call it a vendor discrepancy or customer discrepancy. And then I have to input in their system with dropdowns of,
Sam Binder: is this, what kind of a return is this? And then I have to fill out, I have to justify. And then it's basically like the proof. It's like going to court, right? It's on me to prove to them. But that is brilliant because now they're not, it's all automated from there. I submit it, and it goes off to the claims team for review, and they're going to come back and argue or whatever, present their information that it was system tested before it shipped, and did you try this, and can you send pictures? Everything, though, is in their system, and so the automation is higher.
Sam Binder: And then I can report. Thank you. How many DOA claims did I have and what period? I have access to that data. And what they see and what we want to see, how many customers are incorrectly claiming, what is the trend, and do we have a problem FSE? Do we have a problem customer that is saying like, you know, 60% of the parts they buy from us, they're claiming are bad and they're not bad, I'm gonna stop working with that person. The data is there, but it's because I filed it as a customer. So in the tool, we could build in a button that picks them through a sequence of events.
Sam Binder: where they are responsible. The auto notifies the returns team.
Jake Herwaldt: And updates sales force with information.
Sam Binder: Yep, and it could kick it off to the right, like someone has to take detective chat team because right now it's.
Jake Herwaldt: It's email, it's the email.
Sam Binder: And then go through conversation.
Jake Herwaldt: There's a software, thinking of this.
Vikki Dipple: all these vendors, Block was just another, and I got an email from- window of this product, return has been submitted, sourcing the note, here's all the details, then you as the vendor can do whatever your internal process based on the information given the return process. So that way, for Block, we want an automation to happen because.
Vikki Dipple: we want to keep up with it. But for any other vendor saying, hey, this returns information, blah, email, whatever they want to do.
Jordan Clark: We can certainly make the, like, I feel like once we have the part in our hands, there's improvements that can certainly be made. The biggest struggle we have with the return process currently, especially on the internal buyer side, is just getting it from site to warehouse. Just making a streamlined, easy process for...
Aly Boggs-Smitley: A second to that, I would say paperwork.
Jordan Clark: Yeah, which is probably secondary to that the biggest challenges aren't once it's in the door Yeah, that that system could improve not within the scope of this project currently.
Jake Herwaldt: Using game the FSD to actually ship it.
Jordan Clark: Getting the parts actually moving and physically on our location because we have even when we buy from a vendor We have all of those parts shipped to this warehouse for processing They don't go directly back to that vendor by default there. We will make exceptions, but, So everything should be coming here for processing to verify serial numbers to take photos of the parts to have you know Proof and evidence that we need to ask you something with the vendor, The bulk of our issue is getting the level of engagement with the old engineers.
Jordan Clark: And getting these parts back to us sometimes in a timely manner, oftentimes.
Andrew Bailey: review transit and review but that piece you just touched on that is it correct in saying that that problem is.
Jake Herwaldt: Majority of the time because I would assume if it's dead on the ride that best You don't have an issue getting it back because they're desperate because they need the replacement.
Erica Smith: They are not desperate to get that.
Jake Herwaldt: The process doesn't work like we're not gonna send you a replacement until you send us the few not at all.
Sam Binder: Because they're hard down and if it's our fault if you send a do a part We scramble to get sometimes we nfo a replacement to them at our cost Get that system of the rain could be down a second day to pass them thousands even if the part like you don't actually know.
Jake Herwaldt: It's actually don't actually know but then do you continue continue to charge them though until they say.
Vikki Dipple: Figure out all the actual results when they get these parts those two.
Jordan Clark: two weeks, But again, on the service side, the invoice rate doesn't matter. So that's really the challenge is if it's an external customer. I would say the 80% of the time, we pack it over and we suck it to your car. We don't want them to pack it because they always do that. So we have very specific high-quality packages. So they'll eventually solve it.
Jake Herwaldt: There is an incentive for them to send it back. But our service people, they're not going to solve it because at times money, they need to go to the next place.
Jordan Clark: There's no dollar value associated with it for them. There's no incentive to escalate that process.
Erica Smith: We've got to wrap this up. And they're blocking employees. And also, you always need to get a better deal.
Sam Binder: That's a better block. Yeah, and what she had touched on earlier is a lot of times there's this speed of play. Like that car down, they rushed through it, and it's the middle of the night, and it's 6 a.m., and they got another call, that system's finally running. Oh, we need you halfway across town, three-hour drive, because it went down. Well, they just left the hospital. They might not be back. That exchange is there, but it's like, are you going to reconvene after lunch? Because that engineer is going to come.
Steve Muniak: No, you guys are on your own. We've got to go. Any other humble we can fill here.
Erica Smith: What's the I? I for Erica.
Erica Smith: It's my question. What could be...
Sam Binder: Do you want to just say it and see.
Erica Smith: It would be more sales-driven. I will say, we might have just requested that part two and a half weeks since the engineer remembered that I just replaced it. There's nothing in the course that indicates that. Put that out there to keep it...
Erica Smith: as you're developing this process.
Jake Herwaldt: Then you could be replacing a warranty part.
Erica Smith: And we're not.
Steve Muniak: We get a lot of that.
Andrew Bailey: Thank you very much. You're welcome. One quarter of your team was gone this morning. We appreciate it.
Erica Smith: One quarter of my team's gone. The third quarter took one. I'm hoping she comes in because she's sick. She's like two weeks out. End of this due. I'm always waiting for the call of, I'm always waiting for her. And she's having a discount.
Erica Smith: Like okay. I hope that works out.
Andrew Bailey: Oh, I thought we were meeting, aren't we seeing people? Oh, I see.
Nathan Bedford: Nathan's the best. I really need A.I. to tell me.